e
e e
this
here I wonder if it's my op head's in it
yesterday all right 63
63 good morning everybody we're going to
get going here um start by the Pledge of
Allegiance uh representative Brown why
don't you lead us this morning
thank you representative uh Mr clerk
when you are ready could you call a
rooll
please okay uh Vice chairman in power
present representative guthy
K is here represent lales here
representative Ella representative
Kelly representative awood here
representative Brown here representative
kahill here representative stavis here
representative Tetro here representative
T 11 representative Gilman here
represent JY here representative
Gallagher representative Hicks here
representative Holland here
representative priest here representa
Frack here and Mr chairman
here okay uh first up on our list today
is Senate Bill 63 relative to the
adoption of Public Health ordinances by
municipalities we'll open up the hearing
on that and I see Senator gray here to
introduce the bill
uh thank you Mr chair uh my name is
James Gray I am uh senator from District
Six which starts up in Alton Gilton
comes down Route 11 to
Rochester uh the bill in front of you
63 uh has a story uh it did not start
off with the bill that you see in front
of you uh in fact that bill its Origins
was a house bill uh 15
before uh and uh I needed a house bill
to put uh uh the new voting machine
language uh on uh such that they take
taking out the language that is specific
to the acote machines uh which you guys
have already dealt with uh so I put that
language from House Bill 154 into uh
Senate Bill 63 because I believe it
hadn't Mar
um I did not uh agree with the way it
was done there and have uh suggested
several changes as we've gone along
originally I put in the words that it
the condition uh that Health officer
could regulate had to be unique uh to
the uh town uh for them to work on and
uh there was push back from the health
officers and other people about that
so that the bill that you see that was
passed by the Senate uh went through a
quite a uh um several iterations of uh
negotiations between uh the Senate and
the health Officers
Association uh all in trying to get us
to where uh we were trying to do uh get
to uh and that the health officers be
limited to the original intent
is that they would be able to deal with
nuisances in their
communities
um right now uh the words are nuisances
and other similar okay and that was
again very
um painfully I'm going to say uh
negotiated with the health officers to
get the people on board so that they
could deal with this uh the concept of
nuisances as the attorneys tell me is
well defined in law uh so adding
additional language as I've seen in an
amendment that may be proposed uh later
uh is not necessary uh it will not by
defining it as a nuisance as another
similar it will not let them put in Mas
mandates you know in a pandemic it will
not uh require be able to require um
people to get vaccinations it will not
allow them uh as Atkinson tried to do in
the testimony provided by the
representative during the Senate hearing
allow them to restrict tattooing only to
licens Physicians and if I go way back
uh it will not allow them to ban liquor
uh or ban smoking or ban anything else
because those would not come under the
nuisances uh so again I like the way
that the bill is written right now I can
support the way the bill is written
right now and uh I hope that you will
see uh the wisdom in what the Senate has
done and pass the bill as it's presented
to
you thank you for your testimony uh
representative Brown could you get the
blue sheet and the any pink cards that
are up there for
this uh questions representative lales
yes Senator uh thank you for your
testimony um the term nuis
nuisances or other other similar threats
to Public Health can you give me an
example of that that's that's kind of a
broad brush there can you give me an
example
um the example that I was using when I
was talking with the representative uh
was that if there was a uh a noxious
odor that was coming from either a
company or um a a you know septic system
or whatever that that would be uh if uh
you know again the the attorneys tell me
it's well defined in law okay what a
nuisance is and what a nuisance isn't
and that uh I think the amendment that
uh representative Harvey bullers has has
some examples in there uh but I don't
believe that that's necessary I think it
will uh hinder uh any enforcement of
that in the future uh because you will
have cited some and not others and that
right now since it again I'm going to
use the term well defined in law that
you get everything that's in there right
now you don't get limited to anything
else but it will not include the things
that we were most concerned about when
we started this bill and that is things
that are of a uh Regional or a uh State
you know uh you know where again Mass
mandate it couldn't you couldn't do that
you couldn't mandate um vaccinations you
couldn't mandate certain things follow
up Mr chairman follow up
um so I guess the term
nuisance you would recognize it if you
saw it or you would recognize it if you
smelled it but it and it is defined in
law so it is
purposefully rather
nebulous I would say that that was fair
that you know again to you and I it may
be nebulous to an attorney okay who has
all this case law to go back on I don't
believe it is nebulous okay so you
know the health officer needs to be
educated and other things they'll need
to be educated in this and if if there
is a question uh that's why we have it
in statute so that you the citizen if
you disagree with the decision they've
made can say that's not a nuisance site
why you you think it's not a nuisance
and go forward with thank
you representative priest yeah thank you
Mr chairman sir would you
classify a pandemic like covid as a
nuisance
no represent
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for introducing the bill son Senor
my question is Could you um tell me
where in statute nuisances are defined
uh I can't again I depended upon the
Senate's attorney uh to instruct me in
this and he told me it was well defined
again the statute isn't the only thing
it's decisions from the various courts
uh that help to define the statute so um
in addition to going and looking in the
rsas you would also have to go into
Court decisions especially Supreme Court
decisions that uh would Define
it representative
maor thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question um if if
I if I heard correctly it's it's kept
intentionally nebulous to give the the
health officer some
latitude well you know the words that
are in there right now says says if you
go back to the original statute they had
the ab ability to regulate nuisances
then we add a little bit and then we add
a little bit and that's what started to
cause the confusion so we're trying to
get back to that original intent the
nuisances and to get to a place where we
could get agreement that's why we said
other similar things okay and the
attorneys again told me it's well
nuisances is well defined
okay so to you and I it may be a little
nebulous to an attorney they tell me
it's well
defined followup thank you Mr chairman
and that's kind of where I wanted to go
and it maybe I'm just not understanding
it if if it's similar threats and
similar relates back to nuisance and
what we're trying to do is tighten the
language I'm not sure who's defining who
has the authority to Define
similar in the instance where they are
out in the public is this similar to a
nuisance or not because I agree that I I
haven't asked a question who defines
what similar is I will refer back to the
question that I answered from one of the
previous reps is that I can tell you
easier what it's not it's not the
pandemic items coming from the pandemic
it's not those kind of items okay and
when I I get to other
items it is worthy of a
discussion repr sen Brown thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question Senator I guess you mentioned
earlier on in your testimony that uh the
issue is with the getting Public Health
officials educated on what nuisance and
how these how this is going to be
interpreted how is that going to happen
especially since we have questions
already and we're adding things here
that specify it a little bit more but
you're saying the nuisance and this type
of thing they need to have education
who's going to do that for Health and
Human Services has a group that helps to
uh to do all that with the health
officers
so
followup so with the with the same
followup they they already have this
ability to get the training and yet we
seem to have problems interpreting the
nuisance portion of this how is this
going to make it better better as
opposed to the training that's currently
available the language of the original
bill I don't know that I have it with me
I think I
do
um or the the the statute as it is
before it was amended by the bill
um after it talked about nuisances and
then it says they can regulate other
whatever okay and that's part the part
that caused the confusion and caused
them to be able to think that they could
do other things and that's why we're
trying to get back to that concept of
nuisances so that they don't have
authority to do other things and like I
say I don't think I have that part of
the statute right here it's just a stri
stri out part if you look at the stri
out struck out
part okay relating to Public Health so
they could do anything that related to
Public Health according to what they
thought and that's certainly not what I
want them to be able to do
representative
stavis thank you Mr chair so um RSA 147
is very well defined and in fact grants
to health officers broad um Authority
and judgment to make make calls to
protect people from public health
hazards excuse me and other kinds of
nuisances why Tinker with the
wellestablished statute why not just
come out with a bill that bans mask
mandates if that's what you want H
that's not what I want what I want is
the health officers to stay within the
box that the legislature has D drawn and
legis you know Health officers in
Atkinson who decided that only a uh a
doctor uh can do a
tattoo um you know all the way back to
1972 uh when somebody said well gee
alcohol is a health risk so I'm going to
ban that and another state you know and
we we look at during covid and all the
people who were the health officers were
trying to to regulate things uh that
were not unique to their towns that were
not
nuisances um and so they in my opinion
uh they got out of the box uh and
certainly the Genesis of this bill that
comes from House Bill
154 uh the majority of the house members
uh passed that and sent it on to us in
the Senate so that certainly was a
concern uh that uh uh they were getting
away from what the intent of the
legislature was so that's the reason uh
when
someone you know takes words in the
statute and um manipulates them or
interprets them uh in in a way that was
not intended in the beginning um what is
the legislature to do either accept what
they did or to file a bill that brings
that uh language back into line and
so the representatives here in the
general court said well we're going to
bring them back in line and and that
started with House Bill
154 um when I uh took that bill and used
it for something else I put the your
language or the intent of your language
into Senate Bill 63 so both this the
house and the Senate have already taken
a position that something needs to
change in that statute and that it is
not being interpreted the way the
legislature wants
it representative
yella thank you uh thank you for taking
question
um is
your goal with this to essentially have
some delineation between what is handled
by DHHS and what is handled by the local
municipality that if if it's handled by
DHHS then uh kind of the local
municipality can help enforce those
types of things but they're not to go um
beyond what
DHHS is saying for you know the bigger
health health uh emergencies across the
state that question is getting far
beyond what this bill does uh I will
give you my opinion my opinion is that
there needs to be a collaborative and a
Cooperative uh effort between uh Health
and Human Services and the health
officers uh and when either side uh
starts to stray too much from what uh
the intent of the legislation is that we
need to look at the legislation and
modify it and that's exactly what has
happened in this
case uh representative
Gallagher um so regarding the amendment
um so I'm just wondering where it says
um such as currently um if that were
changed to including but not limited to
representative G
representative gray is
uh discussing his he's not discussing
the amendment I thought he had mentioned
that was I I thought he was saying I
certainly did mention the amendment that
it possible uh and said that uh um that
as the language that I I reviewed
beforehand I did not support uh because
it was not part of the negotiations
between the Senate's attorneys and the
health officers uh when we reach the
agreement on the language that you see
in front of you my my only point was I
prefer to stick to what Senator gray uh
I know we're going to have a
representative speak to the amendment in
a few
minutes F the questions a representative
H uh thank you for taking my question so
uh this is kind of a followup on what
representative yala said so rather that
because again the statute is
intentionally Broad in terms of what
nuisances are and this makes it even
broader with like similar threats which
is not defined instead of saying what
the municipality can't
regulate why not have a bill that says
what the state does regulate and that
way when there's something like the
pandemic and the the municipality is
unsure it clearly delineates where the
responsibility is for who is actually
implementing the law and then holds them
responsible for for if they are or they
aren't um my answer to that is don't
have a crystal ball representative and
if I if I knew you know what to write
down uh I wouldn't have to be vague in
any of these okay so um again you know
the conversation with the attorneys goes
back to the
original legislation that we had talked
about nuisances they expanded that in
years past uh for other things okay and
we're trying to bring it back you know
towards that new es and that's why you
know the definition of nuisances being
well defined in law and you know not
only through the rsas but through Court
decisions about what a nuisance is or
isn't uh gets us to where I need to
be representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I was
wondering if since the wording is that
Health office of a town may make
regulations do you feel that um the
ending of that says when approved by the
Selectmen is a
safeguard uh certainly the Selectmen are
part of the process now and uh if you
look at the original Bill 154 it went
further into that with Town meetings and
everything else uh certainly I didn't uh
think that that was necessary and that
away uh but the uh there needs to be
some check and balance on the health
officers and uh you know having that be
the selectman is fine with
me representative
maor thank you Mr chairman thank you
senator for taking another question um
and this might be more confirmation
since we don't have a we don't have a
hearing report on this do I understand
correctly did I hear correctly that the
health Officers Association support
63 and and the language that is in here
now uh the last statement I remember is
they do not uh any longer oppose it I I
will not go to the the part that says
they support it okay the health officers
and since I didn't do the negotiations
and anything that I tell you is hearsay
uh because I didn't uh do that I I think
I did get an email that says they didn't
oppose it but again that's you know I I
am almost 75 and you know I I I don't
remember every email that I got so thank
further uh representative
stavis uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking another question so has
there been a public hearing on this bill
uh there was several public hearings on
this bill on this particular iteration
of the bill yeah there was if you look
back in the docket uh that we uh
published the uh Amendment or or this
exact version probably not this exact
version okay that's exactly what I meant
well again you know you have rules on on
germanness in this and if you look at
the bill that was that did have the
public hearing and the information that
uh that was in there and talked about
unique situations Etc uh
certainly um you know that uh let's see
I had written uh such other
regulation uh um relating to Public
Health for conditions unique to the town
okay those were changed and it goes it
went back to the uniqueness so um I
don't expect you guys to have a a public
hearing on every Nuance that's changed
uh but the intent is clear uh both uh in
the bill that did get the public hearing
and what you see in front of you is that
uh we want to get back to that
definition of uh
nuances uh and things that uh are uh in
the privy of the health officer to
control because it's Unique to that town
or uh important to that town in
the follow up Mr chair followup uh thank
you Mr chair so just to be clear and so
I understand
I see in the docket that there was a
public hearing on S
sp63 which was an an act enabling
municipalities to adopt a tax credit for
qualified private community property
owners correct and there was a public
hearing on the bill that pertained to
elections but there's no public hearing
on S sp63 as it came comes before us to
if you will look into there you will see
the amendment and the public hearing was
held on the amendment I'm not trying to
educate you on procedure but both in the
house and the Senate until the body acts
the title of the bill does not change
and that is only accomplished when an
amendment is adopted by the body okay so
the title didn't change until that
amendment was accepted uh and that's why
when we publish the amendment we
published the amendment by the amendment
number and uh and uh that the public
hearing is and we make the amendment at
least available if not uh but it was
there at the public hearing and uh you
can see the public hearing report if you
go in and look and clearly um
representative buer uh you know Harvey
bullier was there uh testifying against
it they are testifying to it uh the
health officers were there uh um again
you know again I'm not trying to educate
you on the the policy uh but this is
same thing that happens all the time in
these house
committees for the questions excuse me I
have one Senator um so talking about
nuisances we we see that in uh RSA 147
it's actually very well defined uh you
stated that the attorneys believe that
nuisances are well find and I probably
agree with that looking at your at the
sp63 wouldn't
it rather than adding striking out that
language and adding or other similar
threats to Public Health why not just
strike out that one sentence wouldn't
that get us to where we want to be where
it's just nuisances because I agree that
when you start trying to Define
individual things it it becomes watered
down and pretty much useless in trying
to get to an agreement to consensus with
the health officers okay um they wanted
words in there that talked about other
similar things so again you know is the
bill perfect the way it is you know if
you ask me no but it is perfect enough
that I can I can support it and as I
said before I believe that the health
officers have said that they no longer
oppose it okay very good so we we're
trying to get to that sweet spot where
nobody is completely happy but everybody
says yeah we've done the right thing
gotcha representative kahill thank you
Mr chair thank you senator for taking my
my question don't don't you think that
we should be looking for the approval of
the people and not necessarily the
health officers I mean striking striking
the language as suggested by by our
chair I think would be the right thing
to do and and the people is who we
should be looking out for not the health
officers again representative that's why
you're a representative you know is you
have an opinion okay who is the right
people to um guide me uh who was
supposed to have the knowledge of uh how
different compounds or different odors
different situations are going to affect
me that's the health officer and through
statutes we have have invested both in
health and human services and the health
officers in the towns certain
responsibilities for providing us the
correct information detailed information
about that and so I am going back the
way the statute was in in the original
form is that yes these Health officers
have special knowledge and that that's
why we consulted the health
officers follow up do sir to your
knowledge do you know if every single
town or municipality has a health
officer I believe that the state when
they don't have a health officer uh
performs those
duties okay representative power thank
you Mr chairman and thank you senator
for taking a follow-up question is it
true that some nuisances require
immediate attention and therefore it
would um not be impractical to for
example wait till to for an annual
meeting to get the approval of the
legislative body if if it's a town I
believe that that is
correct further
questions seeing none thank you very
much senator for your testimony uh next
up we have representative Harvey
bolo thank you very much how's everybody
doing
um for the record my name is
representative Juliet Harvey bullia I
represent bellnap District 3 tolton and
samton and I have passed out a packet
for you um and uh you also have an
amendment um that would be amendment
number oh
um 155 yes thank you um so um Senator
gray just did a very good job of
basically introducing everything um and
I appreciate all the work that has been
done on the other side of the wall with
regards to this issue um members of uh
the house have been working on this
particular section of the RSA since
2020 um and I've included in the packet
a recent Bill history it it probably
goes back farther than that but as far
as um what I've done on this particular
section
is here under recent Bill history um
when this bill under house bill
1272 um and I have included the language
here a very similar version of it passed
uh on the cons consent calender by this
committee um and it went on to the
Senate but um so what what prompted the
what prompted this bill in the first
place um was obviously I think everybody
knows at this point the uh the The Mask
mandates but I don't want to say that
this bill is about mask mandates it is
not limited that by any means whatsoever
um so I appreciate your Indulgence in
thinking about it as a whole um as is
already sort of been uh talked about by
Senator gray but um personally um I went
to my select board and in my town and um
my select man said that he would prefer
uh if he could place everybody under a
vaccine mandate for the entire town at
this time it was the height of the covid
pandemic and I thought well sure as heck
I do not want to be wake up one day and
have a vaccine mandate uh addressed to
me and myself my my whole town
um now I just want to sort of address
the fact and I have put in if you look
on page
three there is I've put in the entire
title 10 Public Health chapter as it is
seen uh if you look in the rsas it's got
the title and everything I think it's
very telling that it's about nuisances
toilets drains expectoration rubbish and
waste um and some Representatives have
brought up well you know obviously
the legislation uh is pertains very
broadly and that has been how it has
been interpreted by some is extremely uh
broadly it says um and the the
actionable Clause here is you know and
such other regulations relating to
Public Health that's what the discussion
is
about as in their judgment the health
and safety of people
require so some have brought up well
that's a cart blanch but I would argue
for two reasons it is not for
one there is no requirement for any
public hearings
whatsoever um if you read it shall take
effect when approved by the selectman in
a possibly as little as just a public
meeting so it doesn't even necessarily
have to be listed on the agenda they
simply have to pass it at a public
meeting and post it to me that begs the
idea that this is really what possibly
they meant to write is they may make
regulations for the prevention and
removal of nuisances and
other and other similar things to
nuisances as uh Senate Bill 63 now
stands they meant it as obviously to be
limited to such local things as uh
nuisances and we'll get into the
definition a little bit in a little bit
um so for one that is why um we have
that uh you you got um you know it would
have been so when Selectmen make
regulations and ordinances usually it's
requires public hearings it's there's a
there's a process when you have a zoning
amendment requires two public hearings
is there's a it's extensive um what has
to happen in order for a zoning
Amendment to pass the two public
hearings it's it's in the
statute um so in my opinion that and the
title of this section does not uh Bell
any sort of cart blanch to make any sort
of law that they think is vaguely
relates to Public Health
or uh any sort of thing that could be
construed as public
health um okay so I have put in
so you know by the uh history of the
bill which um Senator has already
introduced um and at the bottom of page
one uh it's got the role of the health
officer this is just taken off the
health officer website for our state um
they have
broaden authority to investigate public
and sanitary concerns um Health officers
shall inquire into all nuisances and
other causes of danger these may include
and they list the tip typical things
garbage pests and sanitary conditions
septic failures rodents and more um
there are no training or qualification
requirements Beyond providing your
criminal records
history um and you get a three-hour
training course and I'm not saying there
are some health officers who have
degrees in public health but by and
large for most
towns um this pertains to the health
officer which also maybe for instance in
our town does other things is also a
selectman um and they're possibly
wearing multiple hats they have taken a
three-hour
training and that is all that they they
are have otherwise they're an employee
on page two I've um listed a whole bunch
of items because in the past I've
received questions about well what about
you know asbest and what about bed bugs
and so uh these this page on page two is
a just a list of all the different rsas
covering all sorts of other things that
Health officers have to deal with and I
think the reason why Health officers
generally don't show up to this to these
types of hearings I'm I'm wondering if
you know they don't want extra hoties
because if you look at this this is
their plates are full and this is a
partial list it goes on to page three
this is by no means the end of the list
it is there's quite a bit in there and I
uh I invite anyone to go on to the
website there's little
um little little Pages um for each
subject matter one of them is
communicable and infectious diseases
which at the end of the packet after I
guess it would be page nine but it's not
listed there's a section called
communicable and infectious diseases and
just you know the reason why I bring
this up is because I want everyone to
see that it's in no way does has DHHS in
any of the guidance documents I've read
through ever Advocate mask mandates
Health mandates keeping lists of um your
guests tatto uh ordinances against
tattoo parlors or that would inhibit uh
requiring the requiring of extra
licensing for
businesses so um under this communicable
diseases uh ADV uh guidance from DHHS it
is the goal the role of the health
officer is mainly a supportive role of
reporting cases of disease educ
dispensing of educational materials
posting Signs regarding swimming or
contaminated beaches so I can't find
anything on in here um
about uh passing ordinances I mean you
know or other such things um so that it
is quite consistent with all the
documents um on their
website uh to limit as Senator gray said
this language is is very important to
keep Health officers when within their
box I think they'll actually appreciate
this and having it defined and having a
more tightly uh written language for
them to adhere to um
so in your packet as well I have
um a couple of
examples on page four it's an ordinance
by the town of hover I just wanted to
give you some examples of mask mandates
this one number
39 is the mask mandate for Handover it
sites New Hampshire RSA 147 colon 1
under the authority
um there were probably six towns that
had mask ordinances and
cities um and they did use this um
particular
RSA this mask mandate uh that Han
Hanover wrote pertains to applies to any
outdoor area where where where
businesses have uh are doing
business um it mandates that um
businesses must sh you know post the
requirement for a mask and it only
pertains if you look at number seven to
certain
zones um so I assume they are they think
that people are familiar with their
zoning um under number eight it pertains
to children under the age of two or up
uh Age Two or
older um so you know we're this is I
guess to just to to give you an idea of
how comp complex some of these laws are
it's not simply we pass a mask mandate
it's going to expire at a certain
time you know and it's very
temporary um we got Lebanon has their
own they also site RSA 47 colon
17 um it is applies to any business
governmental or nonprofit owned business
and also public
transportation okay
and they have it apply to Children three
years of age and
up that also has an effective date but
no expiration
date so at the PO bottom of page six I
get into a few of the business related
ordinances um that have passed things
that um make it difficult for businesses
to establish themselves in town
otherwise legal businesses that have
their own New Hampshire licensing
requirements uh we have tattoo parlors
and massage parlers are seem to be the
main issues here so um on page seven you
have an example of the exiter health
regulations and other establishment
establishing a license a separate
license if uh they they want to
establish a massage parlor for lack of a
better
therapy um
under let's see the application section
under license 123.3mi
Atkinson has a very similar one and it
also cites RSA 147 colon one under um at
the top of page eight it says that the
purpose of the ordinance is to protect
the safety Health and Welfare so it
seems to be again where they've taken
the uh the Clause any other regulation
and and and had quite a bit of Liberty
with it I would
say um
so just to briefly touch on and I'm
almost done I'm wrapping it up
um okay one more example is the tattoo
parlor where on page eight under article
three this is where it says that only a
qualified physician shall Mark the body
um of any other person by means of a
tattoo that some would construe I'm not
going to assign motive but some would
construe that as an effort
to keep out undesirable businesses uh
from town and then you have the uh
Albany still has on this on their books
and on their website as of today this
sort of ordinance that that uh prohibits
the possession of alcohol on public
streets doesn't say whether it's an open
Bott bottle or not I assume they mean
open bottle but it doesn't say
that so um about this the whole subject
of new
definition um so I have not been able to
find a definition of nuisance in our
statutes that pertains to this public
health there are some definitions that
pertain to like things to do with drug
uh controlled drugs and and other
sections firefighting I think but
nothing not that I have seen um yet but
the New Hampshire Public Health nuisance
task force in 2010 did have a task force
and a 27 page document that has and I'll
send everybody St the link um for the
sole purpose of investigating this
particular portion of of law um so I
think I hope you all read it but um so
it says that they're from their from
their uh document that they put out they
express the need to better understand
and Define RSA 147 nuisances toilets
drains
Etc um to achieve this goal a public
health nuisance task force was formed
comprised of a diverse group of
professionals and it's a very good
document um there's a lot in there one
of the things that's not in there though
is sort of a suggestion any kind of
suggestion in any way that Health
officers stray from such ordinary things
as uh that is defined and they do Define
what a public health nuisance is in this
document I have put that uh definition
at the bottom of page eight
nuisance defined this is uh just copy
and pasted from the
document and I'm not going to read it to
you because it is exactly what you would
think it is um it interferes with the
use and enjoyment of property and um is
related to land use basically uh it is
not about uh an individual's Behavior
Etc um so that is why if if uh the chair
is
okay and with me discussing my Amendment
the reason for my
amendment is that a permissible um you
may if you could kind of make it a
little quick yes because we are already
way behind oh okay sorry um so I I
created this amendment
um based off of the list uh from the New
Hampshire Health Officers Association
which is on page three um which they
suggested that they needed these sort of
things um to act on in an emergency
groundwater contamination septic breach
hazardous waste release and flooding
scenarios this is directly from their
suggestion
and I have had um requests to firm up
the language um because we are not
lawyers I suppose and a lot of
uh individuals read this uh for instance
well I mean this applies to towns and
the legislative body of the towns are
their
voters so it seems to be that we want
something that is specific enough for
the lay person to understand what other
similar threats might be so I have put
in other similar threats such as
groundwater
contamination as far as pasas septic
breaches Etc and that is to give the
public an idea of what that is supposed
to mean and also the health officers so
that they might might understand that as
well and I apologize if I went too long
um thank you very much if you have any
questions thank you for your testimony
comments question uh representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so U I
understand that um as an example of an
overreach and application of RSA
147 would be what we saw during the
pandemic with regards to
covid would masks or vaccines either
prevent or
remove covid which was construed to be a
nuisance thank you very much
representative your question is would
would would masks no um I don't believe
so um I haven't found any information to
the the contrary
masks were not in fact I believe I had
testimony before this same committee
last
year where I studied the different mask
mandate different towns that had enacted
mask mandates and their rate of
covid and by comparison there they were
no different than their immediately
surrounding towns thank you
representative priest thank you Mr uh
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh do you think that an
outbreak of communicable diseases like
measles or
hepatitis would be a nuisance under your
Amendment thank you for your question
representative uh no no not nuisance so
nuisance even if it's not defined in
rsay is actually defined in the
dictionary so I assume and I'm not an
expert in the sort of what the lawyers
would say in a court case but if it is
not
defined um nuisance the common
definition I would assume still uh is
defi is that that particular definition
would still apply So Co is not a
nuisance but any other sort of
[Music]
thing that is that is the operative term
here thank you I hope that answers your
question for the comments of
questions I have one for you uh
um over here
representative oh
sorry um the original language that was
in HB
154 and just a very quick answer do you
think that is better than either of
these the two amendments that are
sitting before
us uh thank you for your question
chair I
I I I think the priority
is to limit I think the priority is is
either Senate Bill 63 or with all due
respect my amendment I think that is the
priority here is to Define this properly
I think that is the most important thing
at this this time I think it's my
original House Bill 154 which um is in
here I put it here it
uh it doesn't limit anything I I just
want to know if you thought which one
was better in your opinion that's all
yes okay thank you representative
yella thank you um it seems like you've
done a lot of research on this are you
familiar with any power of um like the
legislative body
or DHHS to identify like the overreach
let's say in the tattoo parlor or let's
say Banning alcohol on all streets um or
the possession of alcohol on all streets
when they when the legislative body or
the um DHHS identifies that as being
outside of the scope of what is
reasonable do they ha have you found any
power granted to those people to be able
to affect that change so that you know
the legislative body could I don't know
resend the health ordinance or the d uh
DHHS has the the power to say this is
not appropriate this is uh you know have
you seen anything like that or is it
just up to the health officer and maybe
the
Selectmen that's a great question
representative yo Kella um I have not
seen anything uh as far as a clawback I
assume there's a possibility that
there's a rule
somewhere um but I haven't heard of any
instances of that happening thank
you representative
Gallagher um so about the amendment um
if the such as were changed um to say
including but not limited to instead um
what um would that um change your
thinking on the amendment at
all thank you very much um
representative Gallagher for that
question that's that's an interesting
point that you rais
and I
I I don't think it's personally I don't
think it's
necessary um because or other similar
threats it that doesn't limit it it's
not saying it's giving examples so or
other similar threats is really the
operative that I see it as the operative
phrase here and then my addition of just
such as is just it's sort of like a
helping phrase I for lack of a better
term I I don't think it's necessary but
I don't
I I think the more qualifiers you put on
there also if I'm not sure to be to be
honest seeing no more questions thank
you for your testimony I have one more
pink card but thank you very much is she
coming back
in I don't see her uh meliss
BL no she's not here Richard
representative Brown
all right uh not seeing her we're going
to go ahead and close the hearing on S
sp63 because we are way behind I
apologize to those in the back of the
room uh here for other bills the
chairman once again has underestimated
the timing on the very first bill uh
with that we will go ahead and open up
the Senate hearing on HB uh SB 531
Senator gray I see you are here to
introduce this one
uh thank you for the record my name is
James Gray I represent Senate District 6
which starts up in Alton gilmington
comes down Route 11 to Rochester uh this
one hopefully we can get you uh some of
your time back a little bit um this bill
has to do with local control and that
the state does not need to be involved
in uh background checks of your health
officers um you know certainly they do
have an oversight uh of the health
officers uh as part of the
responsibility but uh certainly the
local governments are well within their
capability of of choosing their health
officers and investigating them uh we
don't uh get involved in a lot of the
other employees that the that the towns
uh hire so uh we don't need to be
involved in this
one representative K uh representative
Brown could you grab me the blue sheet
on this bill please SP 531 questions for
representative gray representative uh uh
Senator gray representative y Kella
thank you uh thank you for your brief
introduction um however reading the bill
it's still it uh it seems like uh in
line two and three the state is still
requiring that municipalities shall
request and obtain the criminal history
information the it seems like the the
change of this law is just to that it
doesn't need to be submitted to DHHS
anymore is that your um pretty much okay
thank
you representative
priest thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you senator for being here has
there been a problem in the local
governments municipalities towns where
um the health officers was a security
risk and this is the reason why we're
having this
law again I believe that the statute out
there is for them to to do this is
existing uh so that if I keep on doing
it then I don't have a problem uh so I I
I can't really answer your question uh
but uh for right now there's no reason
why that needs to be done at the state
level it can be done at the local level
followup represent yes thank you as a
followup was there a problem um with the
localities not doing this not requesting
this as a part of their hiring process
as best I know uh I don't have the the
all of the background on this but when
uh the department came and requested it
of me um it was an ongoing process to do
these background checks and having it
done at the local level uh should save
time and effort uh because when they're
considering people uh they won't submit
people who can't pass a background
check representative power thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
taking my question so just to to to be
clear is it correct in my understanding
that the requirement for the
municipality
to um obtain and then submit the
criminal history record to DHHS was that
for the purpose of DHHS reviewing that
they can they can speak to that when
they come up to testify but uh that's as
uh you know that was part of the
approval process is that uh there be a
background check done
yes further
questions um I have two quick ones for
you Senator um yes sir on the language
itself um there two phrases that I'd
like you to give me a little input on
that one is on on line seven when it
talks about shall employ its discretion
what does that
mean
um
L you get to the bill itself I I
probably would rather the Health and
Human Services uh contact you testify on
that um we can do that okay uh further
that's fine the most of the input that I
had in here is that the original uh
suggestion when it came to me um did not
talk about the Health and Human Services
oversight uh and they still have an
oversight role in this even though
they're not doing the selecting or or
doing the background check and since you
brought up that word that was the other
question I had for you on line nine what
does subject to oversight mean what will
is that something better that they're
going to answer or I would I would think
that the original Bill didn't have that
but when they testified in the Senate uh
they were also espousing that again you
know they do have a role uh in the
health officers activities and so I
wanted this bill as modified to to
recognize that role and I believe that
they will talk to that I'll hold those
questions for them then thank you
further questions for Senator Gray see
you none thank you for your testimony
and I apologize but I do have another
appointment so i' like to say see
you okay I only have uh if there's any
other pink cards anybody wants to speak
on this please make sure you get them up
there uh I have next uh Sophia Johnson
from
DHHS good morning chairman turot and
members of the Municipal and County
government committee my name is Sophia
Johnson and I'm the program manager for
the health officer liaison program at
the Department of Health and Human
Services Division of Public Health
Services thank you for the opportunity
to provide testimony in support of
Senate Bill 531 an act relative to the
background check of Municipal Health
officers Senate Bill 531 is Department
requested
legislation the legislation proposes to
amend RSA 128 section 9 to no longer
require municipalities to send a health
officer candidates background check to
the department as a prerequisite to any
nomination the department has a
legislative mandate to appoint and
assist Town Health officers via one uh
RSA
128 while Town Health officers are
Department appointed they're ultimately
Town employees nominated by a board of
Selectmen and serve subject to local
human resource practices as Town Health
officers are Municipal Employees we
believe that they should be subject to
established local hiring practices prior
to confirmation by the
department the legislation if enacted
would provide local municipalities the
authority to determine what convictions
on a candidate's background check would
be considered disqualifying consistent
with its own established hiring
practices additionally the proposed
legislation would remove the
Department's response responsibility to
review and store candidates background
checks which are sensitive documents
this would eliminate any privacy
concerns related to background checks
the legislation does retain the the
Department's ability for oversight in
the appointment or termination of Health
officers if
warranted in closing the department
believes that Senate Bill 531 restores
local Authority in selecting Town Health
officer nominees reduces privacy
concerns and decreases administrative
burden thank you for your time and I'm
available for any
questions representative McDonald Mr
clerk thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question where can I
find what the disqualifying things would
be for not being a health officer what
would disqualify me from being a health
officer um what would be considered
disqualifying is that what I'm are they
in your rules or where are they um
I know that our rules were amended this
year we actually added rules to RSA 128
and to be honest I would have to review
those rules to determine what is defined
as um being able to be removed may I you
do a followup
absolutely what are the current rules
that you're aware of are there any um I
I am not aware of any at this point okay
thank you thank you representative
yella thank you kind of uh going back to
the your statement about oversight and
specifically around termination
um what does oversight mean like for
example the ones that have been
proferred here today about uh regulating
tattoo parlors um or or Banning alcohol
possession of alcohol in a would would
um
does the DHHS have any power to say hey
you've you've done something
inappropriate and and uh
fix uh either are you guys actively kind
of monitoring them and and uh saying
like hey this is good or this is
approved um or and um if you found
something that was inappropriate do you
have the power to say that this should
not be the uh a health ordinance or or
the person entirely what what is the
scope of the oversight sure that's a
great question so um so we provide um
Health officers that appointment right
like that you are confirmed by the
department to fulfill the requirements
of Health officer law but you are a town
employee so Health officers act in a way
that their towns have oversight over
local laws passing local laws we know
that every town some towns regulate
tattoo parlors and some towns don't but
that's a municipal Authority that we
don't want to overstep that Authority
certainly um in situations where there's
potential groundwater contamination then
de's rules come into play um and Dees
would have additional oversight over
those particular cases so in many
situations that Health officers respond
to they're working alongside another
department so there is that that
oversight as they respond but primarily
if you're question is passing local
ordinances um that's again subject to
the towns requirements that the town's
processes if I'm answering your question
correctly in my tenure I am not aware of
any times that we have had to remove a
health officer towns will come to us if
there's um questionable conduct by a
health officer and we can certainly
review um that history or that activity
that the health officer has engaged in
um but there's never been a situation
rise to the level where the department
has removed someone from the
position
followup okay so but so your statement
is that you've never seen someone
actually be removed
but also implied I guess I want to make
explicit in your testimony is that they
since it is confirmed by DHHS there is a
potential for DHHS to remove that
confirmation and say you are no longer
allowed to be the health officer yes we
certainly have that Authority Within the
law as it is now thank
you representative
Elwood thank you madam Vice chair for
taking my question and um welcome this
morning thank you is it true that um
towns
share Health
officers smaller towns
share so in in certain situations for
small towns it is very hard to find
someone to fulfill this role so one
Health officer may serve in multiple
towns but they need to be appointed in
each of those towns so for example if
the health officer in Chichester is
asked by the town of eping or um to to
serve Epsom then that Health officer can
certainly serve in both towns the
department would just need to um make
that confirmation for them so they can
serve
concurrently thank you yes
representative power thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so is it true that in the um
roles and responsibilities and duties of
a health officer is it would it be true
that they they're dual hated and
that they function um as on behalf of
the state of State departments as as
well as um local
municipalities so they are Municipal
Employees who serve at our request and
very often um you know they conduct
School inspections on behalf um of the
the Department of Education they do
foster care licensing inspections for
the Department of Health and Human
Services um so they act on behalf of the
departments in certain situations um but
they are Municipal Employees I hope that
answers your
question further questions
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
so what's the position on the towns have
they've given you any feedback in regard
to them wanting to take on this
responsibility
so I have received concerns about
privacy that why you know why do I need
to send this to you to be very honest
when we've already done this and this
background check result is satisfying by
our standards why then do you need to
have that additional review process
that's what I've heard follow up Mr
chairman so what I what I really meant
is that U have the towns requested um
that um that that responsibility go back
to them in all cases
the overall responsibility for the
review process of this as opposed
to them having the responsibility and
then the state wanting to take it and
just say we would like this
responsibility our S period so I haven't
gotten that request directly but there
I've gotten concerns about why do you
need to see this that's what I thank
you representative y
Kella thank you thank you for taking
another question um so
so going back to the fact that you have
to confirm essentially authorize even
though the person got hired by the local
municipality you have to confirm at DHHS
that they are allowed to provide this
role what if not the background check
are you using to decide whether or not
someone is appropriate for that role or
not so that's determined at the local
level the town determines what candidate
they would like to serve in that role
they perform the background check and
then they submit that candidate to us
there is no other requirements that we
look for in order to say that's an
appropriate candidate or not it is the
town's
responsibility go ahead follow um so I
guess with your response why even have
your guys'
perun coronation yeah if you will um if
you guys are not ever denying anyone for
any reason I guess why why even have
that
uh legislative or the that um you know
regulatory step yeah it's a great
question so in a lot of cases um you
well always it's important for us to
know at the local level who is the
health officer so in cases of emergency
cases of concerns that come to our level
we want to know who to be able to
contact at that local level um that
information um that Emer contact is very
important for us especially in
situations of emerging concerns or um
emergency situations um and again Health
officers do serve um for the Department
in a number of functions like these
types of inspections of schools and dayc
carees and foster care licensing um so
it's it's important to have an appointed
person to perform that
role representative
kahill thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so you in your
testimony you you're talking about these
these other um things that you're using
the health officers for that are not the
purview of the Town those are separate
agencies do you do
you do you think you
I do the health officers have access to
other private information other
information that they they wouldn't have
through the town through you guys um we
we don't share private um health
information protected Health um
protected health information or
identifiable information except in
situations of communicable disease where
the Bureau of infectious disease um
control if they're investigating a
certain situation in a town they have a
a privacy agreement with the health
officer um the health officer has taken
um all the Privacy um training hipa
training um and that's outlined in RSA
141c there is that protection um an
agreement outlined that health offic
need to have in order to receive
protected health
information further
questions I have one or two um line
seven that I asked Senator gray about
employ it's discretion yes um give me a
little information what exactly does
that mean so um the the sentence States
each municipality shall employ its
discretion when reviewing background
checks so every town may have its every
town has its established hiring
practices and they may have um guidance
on what type of conviction would be
disqualifying and what type of
conviction would not be disqualifying so
the municipality has its ability to
utilize its own hiring practices and
interpretation of qualifying um or
disqualifying convictions to um apply to
this
nomination and second question maybe
simplifying the questions that
representative yella asked about
oversight is it my understanding
that even though the town's going
through the search process would you the
DHS DHHS still have the ability to
basically veto a health officer's
appointment to that town yes we can
thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testing thank you very much and I
believe that's all the pink cards we
have on that anybody else wanting to
speak I see none we'll close the hearing
on HB uh SB 531
all right uh we'll go ahead and open up
the hearing now on SB
447 establishing a committee to study
the inclusion of Transportation expenses
in default budgets Senator ch Ley you
are up thank you very much and good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Shannon chandley
and I have the honor of serving the
people of District 11 in the state
senate um I come before you today to
introduce s SP 447 relative to funding
School transportation services under the
default budget um the bill uh
establishes a study committee something
I know that we are sometimes reluctant
to do because there are so many but I
would submit that this is an efficient
and Nimble way to get some answers about
a very Co um complex subject the
original uh Bill what I originally
intended was to try
to address the issue of um default
budgets uh related to
Transportation um in a single bill but
what became clear immediately is that
the issue is is um complex as well and
and may require the input of more
stakeholders to understand the best
solution um it was a request of one of
the saus in my district that has had uh
to rely on default budgets transport
while uh the SAU is required to
transport some students in certain
circumstances Transportation budgets um
are not included in the default budgets
despite the fact that they are often
contracts um this has become a problem
in some communities and this bill here
does not propose a solution but in fact
proposes a way to get to a solution I
ask that you look favorably upon the
bill and I am happy to take any
questions representative kahill thank
you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question um outside the the
the solution
we probably do need to find a solution
but here on line five it says it be one
member of the Senate and on line six
three members of the House of
Representative do you think that since
the Senate is requesting this that maybe
there should be multiple members of the
Senate equal equal share of
workload um I don't think that would be
the best solution I think that since
there are 400 members of the house
there's a lot of Talent on which to draw
and there are 24 Senators so I really do
believe that the three Representatives
would serve well and um of course the
four members of the subcommittee um
could call upon any stakeholders who
might be able to provide good um uh
information for the
committee representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question um so being very familiar with
the default budget law um the it seems
to me that there if the transportation
was required by law let's say if you're
you're far away from the the school or
whatever the case may be or um special
ed or whatever those things required by
law would be able to be included in the
default budget and if the
contract that you stated um was put
before the vote voters instead of just
signed by the by the uh School Board
then it would be able to be part of the
default budget so I guess my question is
what what situations other than things
that require um are required by law um
and and then the other transportation is
just not a one-time expense so it's
recurring so it would be flat every
single year so I guess what what is
where is that need not being met I guess
in all those three different cases so
from my understanding from my the SAU is
that they were not able to include the
transportation budget in their
calculation now I also did speak to the
municipal Association and they were more
than happy to take part in this um
discussion because they believed that um
we need maybe perhaps greater education
and understanding around default budgets
further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony uh next up we
have thank you yes thank you uh Barrett
Christina thank you chairman turot uh
good morning members of the committee my
name is Barrett Christina I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
school board Association uh speaking in
favor of this bill um as Senator Chanley
stated um the bill doesn't um really uh
provide a solution to some of the
challenges that school districts are
facing with Rising Transportation costs
but hopefully the study committee or the
study commission can can um help uh a
Statewide discussion on what school
districts might be able to do to either
include that in the default budget or to
at least address some of the rising
costs that we've seen relative to School
District transportation I have a handout
here um not a handout but I have a a
short PDF of just to um identify the
rising costs that school districts are
facing with Transportation the Lichfield
School District uh their FY 24 cost was
$371 per day per bus their FY 25 cost is
going to be
$445 per day per bus Dairy
$421 per day per bus uh uh for FY 24 for
fy2
$459 uh per day per bus so we're seeing
um at least a $50 per day um per bus
increase um for transportation costs I
presume there are many reasons for that
uh having a hard time fin to find bus
drivers so those districts are having to
increase their pay or not sorry those
districts but the bus companies are
having to increase pay or have longevity
bonuses or sign on bonuses um I presume
that the price of diesel is also driving
up some of those costs as well too so
anything um that uh uh anytime we can
get a group of stakeholders across the
table to help look at some of these
issues that are impacting local school
district budgets um the school board's
Association is in favor of so we support
the bill and and would be happy to
provide whatever expertise or knowledge
or background or information we could if
indeed there is a a study committee or a
study commission that moves forward and
that concludes my testimony I'm happy to
answer any questions
uh representative
yella thank you thank you for uh taking
the question um kind of alluding back to
my my PRI prior question and and since
it seems like you have some stats um do
do those uh districts that you were
current you were just referencing have a
contract with that bus company that
could have foreseen those increases and
if the that municipal had to put that
contract on the ballot being included in
the default budget um would that have
solved the problem that you're that
you're raising here sure thank you for
the question referee son that's a good
question um most of the contracts that
school districts are signing with
Transportation companies are three to
fiveyear contracts um and one of the
challenges is um I believe there's only
about two companies in the state that
are providing transportation services to
school districts that don't own their
own buses so um it's not a very
competitive market for school districts
in the the superintendent and
Schoolboard members that I've spoken to
that have negotiated Transportation
contracts over the last couple of years
um have have been over a barrel to be
quite honest with you because the
transportation company is saying this is
the cost this is this is what we're
charging you and if you don't want to
sign our contract the school district is
is up a creek and to your question about
um whether or not they could put the
transportation contract on as a separate
warant warrant article um the risk with
that would be there are certain o
Transportation obligations that school
districts have to have to follow special
education as you mentioned
representative and RSA 189 col 6 states
that the local school district shall
furnish transportation to pupils in
kindergarten through eight through grade
eight who live more than two miles from
the school um so if the if the
transportation contract were to go on
the warrant as a separate warrant
article and was defeated I don't know
how that's rectified because you're not
allowed to appropriate money under that
contract then if the voters said no but
you still have statewide obligations to
transport kids for special education and
under and under this statute so you
could bifurcate that that contract
somehow but you'd have to go back and
renegotiate with the transportation
company
no uh yes go
represent
T thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking our ongoing questions on this
item
um the default budget is
defined quite explicitly in the rsas on
what can go in and what
can't but
um
so aren't we kind
of it's already in in the budget so if
they get the default budget the money
that was allocated last year with the
school buses is already in
there are you are you saying that that
the voters well I suppose you could take
that line out at your public meetings
but
um but the other obviously makes up for
it as far as being
ired within Beyond two two miles and
special special circumstances but I
guess my question is is
this already taken
care thank thank you for the question
representative um I guess I would
hearken back to Senator chandy's
testimony where she said in speaking
with one of the school districts in in
in her District in her in her Senate
District that they were either informed
or told or calculated the default budget
absent some of the increased costs that
these new Transportation contracts are
costing I don't know specifically what
district Senator Chanley is referring to
but the fact that the bill was put in
place at the request of Van SA or a
school district because there were
concerns relative to Transportation
costs within the default budget I would
say that that's kind of why we're here
and why the bill was introduced and why
we're having this conversation
repes representative
lales thank you for taking my
question could you tell me in the the
current default budget
situation what transport Transportation
costs are allowed in that default budget
so thank you for the question
representative well in and so the as as
I presume most if not all the members of
the committee are aware of the default
budget includes in its in in in part of
its definition contracts and other
obligations previously incurred or man
mandated by law so special education
would be man special education
Transportation would be mandated by law
the transportation of pupils in grade in
grades kindergarten through grade 8 who
live more than two miles from school
would be required by law a school
district however May provide
transportation to high school students
which is not required by law but yet
would be calculated into into a contract
with a transportation company likewise
the school district may also provide
transportation to pupils in grades
kindergarten through grade 8 who live
less than two miles from school so I
mean I don't know if a could a business
manager or a superintendent of a school
district pinpoint where each child lives
and then ascertain or calculate a cost
per pupil and then that might be taken
out of the default budget
because you're only providing you'd only
be able to put in the default budget the
costs that are required by law the
special education and the for all the
children that are within the parameters
of the of RSA 189
co16 goad followup it's my understanding
although there is this TW mile
rule that most school districts say if
you want to ride the bus we're going to
provide you a ride yeah to the school
whether you
live
um in our district we had one person one
student who lived directly across the
street from the school but the parent
requested right that the child be picked
up because they didn't want the child
walk across the
road so in that case where the school
district is providing
Transportation above and beyond what is
mandated is that included in the
current um default budget negotiations
or calculations yes thank you for the
question representa I'm not trying to be
evasive but I mean I certainly I can't
speak to 161 school districts on how
they're calculating their default budget
well less than that but for the sb2
towns let's say there's 100 school
districts that are sb2 I mean you know I
think I think many school districts
calculate them a little bit differently
to be quite honest with you depending on
the advice that they get from from
perhaps their own local attorney um I
will also tell you that I'm aware of
some school districts that will provide
High School transportation for high
school students but the parents also
have to pay some amount it's probably
not the full amount that covers it but
I'm aware of some school risks that will
say if you're high school whether you
live a mile from the school or 10 miles
from the school
that parents have to pay $100 a year or
something along those lines to help
defas some of those costs okay thank you
thank
you representative stavis thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question this just a simple question I
think um is the origin of this bill the
um the problem of one SAU or is this a
Statewide issue thank you for the
question representative um
I will tell you that and and I know this
doesn't get to the default budget
question I will tell you that Rising
Transportation costs are a Statewide
issue the default budget issue I can't I
can't specifically speak
to follow
up so the factual answer to my question
is that you don't know is that correct I
correct yes that's fair enough
representative priest thank you Mr chair
chairman um and thank you for being here
and for all that you do for the school
districts um again my understanding is
that this bill would look into all those
cases in the towns and
municipalities that have transportation
cost in uh in their budgets and
study this situation because of the
rapidly
changing fuel cost and other costs that
are pertaining to transportation that
they cannot foresee is that correct
thank you very much uh for the question
representative yes to to to some degree
that is why nhba is supporting the bill
aside from looking at the default budget
I believe I led some of my testimony was
saying I hope that perhaps that
conversation can also may not be the
direct purpose of that study commission
but hopefully that would come out in the
conversation of what are some of the
other drivers and what are some of the
other challenges school districts are
facing relative to train
Transportation further
questions seeing that I have one yep um
kind of a 35,000 foot view philosophical
uh you seem to be very knowledgeable
about the situation uh the bill itself
has five senators and five house members
as
sponsors what is the need for yet
another study committee when we have the
expertise I would assume within at least
within the sponsorship yourself and
whoever else to actually work on it
yourselves and come forth with
legislation next year so thank for the
that that that that's a fair enough
question representative um you know the
school boards Association we have a a
continued working relationship with aund
100 superintendents across the state 100
business managers across the state um
again I I have spoken to Senator Chanley
about this bill I don't know what
specific SAU this is a derivative from I
can certainly do that offline if you
will or in the hallway and and and reach
out to that particular School District
as well too and and and and and and
perhaps our own working group if you
will and then find somebody to sponsor
legislation next year thank you thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much testimony we have one more pink
card Eric power
good morning my name is Eric power I'm
from Brookline I'm also the president of
the school district governance
Association in support of this bill uh I
think this bill is important uh
Transportation costs have been going up
we have a lot of school districts
including the the town I live in in
Brookline our K through 6 school
district is
sb2 and what needs to be in a default
budget what can't be there's some
language there in the law um but it's
there is some gray areas and so with
Transportation it's one of the key
things that the school district has to
fulfill um and it's important that you
under this is a complex problem so I
think it's it's appropriate for a uh
study committee to look at this you have
some saus about 75% of the saus in the
state are single District saus so this
the SA serves one school district you
have the other 25% of saus are
multi-district
saus and among those some districts
decide to contract their transportation
individually and some contract them as
an
SAU and bus contracts will range
anywhere from one year which is very
uncommon three to five years so that the
problem comes down when you have an
ongoing contract there's not going to be
a question if it's continuing what the
cost will be that would be put in the
default budget because you know the
contract is going on the question
happens when your contract runs out what
do you put in the default budget for the
next year because you don't have a
contract and that's a good question for
this committee to take a look at because
it's uh there's a couple different
aspects to it in terms of you know
governance so I think that it is an
important committee but I'd also want to
give one caveat at that you know
transportation is one of the costs in a
school district but there can be other
things such as maybe the propane cost
natural gas costs o oil costs you don't
always have a contract with that those
are usually annual based on the market
so while we're looking at Transportation
if this if this committee uh gets formed
you want to also it might open up a
little bit of can of worms on what you
do with other things what you put in a
SP SP2 default budget
that doesn't have a contract and what is
not mandated by law that's a gray area
so um I think this committee could meet
and look at those things but you also
have to be aware there might be some
other areas especially for school
districts where this might be uh an
issue about how to clarify uh what's in
a default budget and I've I've looked at
default budgets closely myself I've
talked to representative yella I found
mistakes in default budgets where they
weren't find following the law um So and
I've also talked to Department of res
Revenue Administration Dr and they say
the number one question they get during
budget season are questions about what's
in a default budget so if this would go
to any amount of helping get less calls
and less uh less Demand on Dr I think
they would greatly appreciate it if we
clarified this part of the law so I
think the committee would be a good
thing to do and see what it comes up
with considering all these factors and
um with that I'll take any
questions representative y
Kella thank you uh thank you for taking
the question it's um the in my
municipality the recent um concern
regarding default budgets was why is the
state deciding what is and is not in the
default budget at all um why is the
state telling us what is in the default
budget and essentially making us pay for
maybe things that we wanted to remove
because we're we went to deliberative
session and and um so I guess my
question to you
is it seems like there's a just a lack
of communication or knowledge about this
and maybe actually there is no no fix
required for
transportation in in they just they
maybe the municipality just needed to be
advised that they need to put that
contract on the on the ballot and be uh
helped by a Dr to to formulated so the
known means no doesn't happen as far as
spending on it so I guess what
purpose with
Transportation
specifically
is is warranted in this
aspect um since it seems like the
municipality if they're going to a
default budget has already spoken of
about they don't want the increased
costs or or they don't like the proposed
budget and and so why is why is are we
coming up with solutions to override
those those voters I guess I think the
thank you for the question I think when
you get tob2 and what goes in the
default budget it is definitely a murky
area and I think that the transportation
question with school districts is
probably a very good case uh subject
area to look at some of these things
because you have sometimes you have a
contract for it sometimes it continues
sometimes it doesn't and I think if you
look at that it might uncover some of
the other defects we have with the
default budget by looking at this case
uh if a if the study committee looks at
that I'm sure that they will see this as
a case example will help maybe inform
other s
SP2 um default budget questions that
certainly need to be looked at so I
think as a you know as a as a prime
example of what happens I think it would
be very useful to have that insight and
for people to hear the different issues
there to help you know not only solve
this Transportation but maybe even the
larger default budget for
SP2 represent K thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um so as you
know we're required in our Constitution
to provide an education um and that's a
financial number uh um well cherish okay
um my question is it seems that
transportation is part of that
requirement right like to get them there
how much of that money allocated goes to
Transportation do you do you know I'm
not I'm not sure if I understand the
question well the the money that's
mandated that's come comes from the
state is any of that money used for
transportation there is adequacy Aid
that comes from the state so it's it's
up to the school district where where it
comes from there's a tax effort part of
the tax effort is going to be from the
state part of the tax effort will become
from the federal government in terms of
special education and other grants so
but that that defrays the tax effort and
the rest of them is paid by local
taxpayers so that's a bigger question
you know um you heard about you know the
Mandate is being more than two miles
away k through eight so if you have a a
co-op School District like I have a 7
through 12 Co-op School District should
if that doesn't have SP2 but if somebody
did have SP2 should that be in the
default budget and right now they do put
it in the default budget if they have a
contract if the contract doesn't
continue I think it depends on who's
asking and who's looking at what's going
on in that school district and I think
that's a an area that's very gray right
now that people do you know what the
attorneys say and and so that's kind of
what you have to look
at further questions representative
Brown
thank you Mr chairman and thanks Mr
power so I think I heard this at least
twice in your testimony that that this
bill is important because of the need to
straighten out the transportation issue
on the default budget but I I also think
that you said that there were a number
of other issues that need to be
addressed with the default budget
so and I I thought you alluded to the
fact that maybe the proposed committee
should address those too did I
misunderstand you I I think that could
be something that they would look at I
think you know transportation is largely
driven by energy so if you look at
energy in terms of what do a school
district
use um I've come across numerous warn
articles over the past few years where
people are doing conversions from
propane to oil doing solar doing all
kinds of things and you know if you have
a market-based fuel like heating oil or
propane you know if the market goes up
the default budgets can have last years
so what are you going to do there it's
the same problem so it seems to me these
sorts of thorny problems should be
handled maybe the transportation piece
can handle that maybe the committee
could add that as another thing to look
at you know these kinds of these kinds
of issues in school districts if if you
need to um I think that that would be
some
insight represent
kill um thank you Mr chair so you know
I'm reading line one right here
committee established there is an
established a committee to study the
inclusion of Transportation expenses in
default budgets I don't see anywhere in
this bill those other things you're
talking about so I don't think that
the
committee being proposed here would
would be able to do those things do do
you agree I agree that the the bill is
now yours and you guys you can make
amendments to it as you see fit based on
circumstances so that's what I would do
if I was on the committee um because
this is a challenging problem and it
could do a lot of good to look at all
SP2 issues F the
questions I have one Mr power it's the
same question that I gave Mr Christina
you obviously have a lot of experience
and knowledge on this issue uh with the
School District Governor uh government
Association governing Association and uh
Mr Christina with the New Hampshire
school boards
Association Along with these sponsors
don't you believe that without forming
an actual committee you could actually
come forth with some legislation that
would take care of the issue that you're
all testifying
for I thank you for the question I think
that could be possible I don't I think
without a committee though there
probably wouldn't be the priority on it
that would happen in sort of an ad hoc
manner we do do a lot of legislation ad
hoc but I think there you know this is a
rare circumstance where you see an
agreement with a couple of different
associations
um so I think that having this committee
look at this it is a challenging issue I
think it's going to require some
research behind it I don't think any
single party has all the answers but it
could be done will it happen on its own
I don't think it
would and I have a followup for myself
um you just mentioned exactly my point
uh you're your two associations are
generally I would assume not in
agreement where you have an agreement
here
I would think that would be the perfect
opportunity for you all to use your
expertise to get together and actually
come up with some good legislation
that's a comment you can answer it's not
really a question but um you know we we
have hundreds of these study committees
and quite honestly I've seen more action
and I uh legislation good leg
legislation come out of um groups
getting together as ad Hawk than I have
as actual committee so that would be my
only comment on that further comments
thank you for the input yeah further
comments questions seeing none thank you
very much for your
testimony anybody else wishing to speak
on
447 seeing none thank you all for coming
Senator we'll close the hearing on that
all right we have one more to do before
lunchtime
okay with that we will go ahead and open
up uh cabil 53
two it's got a long long name so I'll
just dispense with that for now and we
have I believe rep uh Grant brossy is
going to be introducing it on behalf of
Senator Carson
I would defer to Senator Carson who just
got out of her other Prime
bill here we
go I will introduce Senator Carson thank
you Mr chairman and uh good morning and
good morning to the members of uh house
Municipal and County government um
committee I have for the record uh my
name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure of representing Senate District
14 oh it's
on I'm it's
on okay um which is comprised of the
towns of Londoner Hudson and Auburn and
I have for your consideration this
morning Senate Bill 532 relative to
requiring all municipalities and school
governing bodies to post on their
official town or School website within
30 days the amount of funds received by
the state either by allocation or Grant
um you might ask where does this come
from and this bill really comes from me
talking with my constituents one of the
things that many of us if not all of us
do is when we go home we like to talk to
our constituents about what we've done
in conquered and what we've done to help
them make their lives better and we had
a great budget last year very
bipartisan and one of the things I like
to talk about is that bipartisan budget
but also about how much money we've
returned to the taxpayers for property
tax relief and of course the response I
usually get is what
relief where well I don't I didn't see
my property taxes go down and so I
started thinking about well what's the
best way to inform our constituents when
we send money back to the towns and we
do it in a variety of different ways so
um I met with the municipal ipal
Association and I talked to some of my
colleagues I and I talked with my uh
town government in londondary said maybe
the best thing to do is basically every
time you get money from the state put it
up on the town website let the people
know that you're receiving this money
and you could even make it even sweeter
by telling them what you intend to do
with it but at least this way the people
can see that we are giving them money
back that they can use in a variety of
different ways
and hopefully this will spur
conversations between citizens and their
town government and be a way for them to
be more involved so again Mr chair this
bill is is I always hate to say fairly
simple because usually when you say that
some people will see it as pretty
complicated but um it's just asking them
to put just very simply put it up on
their town website the amount of money
they're getting for us both on the
school side and from um on the town side
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
for your testimony I would make the
comment that you're right A lot of times
when somebody says it's very simple it
turns out to be one of the most
complicated I believe this is fairly
simple representative Gallagher I saw
your hand
up
um so
um so it on lines five to six it says in
the absence of a website a political
division shall post the information in
two appr apprpriate places could you go
into a bit more detail about um what is
meant by appropriate
places okay thank you very much for the
question uh representative um this
language was added um because of
concerns that the municipal Association
had we have a number of very small towns
here in our beautiful state and some of
them they don't have a web page so they
will post it in two places that they
feel
are appropriate they could have a Town
Newspaper they could put it as a notice
in the town newspaper or they could put
a notice up at Town Hall um it's going
to be up to them to decide which places
they feel are more
appropriate representative yella thank
you thank you for uh taking the question
um as a member of the budget committee
um is my understanding in my local
municipality it's my understanding that
money going to the school often come if
I'm understanding how how it works the
money actually flows directly to the
municipality and the municipality cuts
the school a check and so um so if that
is the case would the um the school not
need to to post it would just be the
municipality that got the money directly
from the uh state if it was for like a
you know a refund or
something I I think I I really didn't
thank you qu for the question
representative I really did not want to
micromanage this process other than to
say you've got to post it to let people
know that this money is coming back to
you and really it's up to the
municipalities how they're going to
spend that money but at least we've
taken a step and we've said we're giving
you this money back or you're getting
this much money per pupil or you're
getting a sustainability grant for the
schools because most people really don't
know that and sometimes that information
is really buried in town reports I don't
know about you folks when you go to your
town deliberative sessions but our books
are about that thick and it if you don't
know exactly what you're looking for
you're not to find it so this way you're
taking that information and you're
putting it up there uh in a very simple
format um to let people
know representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for taking my question so I think I
heard in your testimony that you said
that this information would be posted on
the website indicating how much money
they received from the state and I
thought you said that also how that
money was going to be used I don't see
that in the bill about how it's
allocated thank you for the question I I
believe that I said it's going to be up
to them to decide if they want to add
additional information including how the
money is to be used thank
you rep uh representative
Elward thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question this says um on
line
five that this um notice will be posted
to the website Within 30 days of receipt
but it doesn't say for how long it needs
to stay
posted or archived for example do
you see it in perpetuity on the on the
website I thank you for the question
representative again I did not want to
micromanage the process at the Town
level um it should pretty much be up to
them how long they want to keep it up um
or if they want to Archive it but I
would think that I I don't want to say
anything else because I I don't I'm not
in town government um and I believe
every District might have their own
policy and again I really did not want
to micromanage this thank you uh rep
representative majori thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
taking a question which I think the
answer might be our discretion but
Northampton just was awarded what
Northampton is going to be the the
recipient of work from the new Hamp from
a grant given to the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation to fix all
the damage from the last storms that we
had I in there that means we are not
going to have to spend our money but the
grant money is not coming to the town I
imagine that might be something we're
going to celebrate anyway but you would
say I I imagine the answer to this would
be use your discretion about how you
want to post that to the
community okay again thank you for the
question representative yes I again I
don't want to
micromanage each Community is different
they handle information differently and
I don't in many instances I don't
believe a one-size fits-all is is really
good representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you senator for um taking my question so
um I appreciate this this bill and it
it's a it's an interesting and a good
idea my concern is I know in my SAU they
bury information and that would be
contrary to what you're the purpose of
the spill is you literally have to be
Nancy Drew I just it's impossible to
find any information so I was wondering
I understand that you don't want a
micromanage and one size doesn't fit all
I is there any solution because this is
important information would you be open
or do you have any ideas as to how we
could address that so that the you know
our constituents and the members of the
public can access that important
information thank you representative for
the question I see this as a first step
I think there needs to be a my personal
opinion is there needs to be a lot more
communication between either a town
counsil or whatever form of government
you have and a school board and the
citizens um I recently found out that um
often times a school superintendent will
um apply for a grant from the federal
government and the Schoolboard members
don't even know they won't know so again
I see this as a first step in maybe
getting people to start talking to each
other um at the local level and just and
I I agree that a lot of times
information is deeply buried in
documents and this is just made to be
very simple very clear very transparent
and hopefully they'll if this does pass
um people will see that this kind of
information being made a lot more
readily available is a great opportunity
to engage citizens in local
government representative priest I saw
your
hand thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh Senator Carson we go back a long way
for 20 years thank you for being here
and thank you for um sponsoring this
bill as I read it this is very simple
you're just increasing the transp
parency M between the state and the
local governments um and the people in
the local governments so they know
exactly what you're doing and what
programs you are adopting and bringing
back to to
them is that correct thank you for the
question representative yes it is
um you know um just so you know
representative priest and I served for
many years together when he was the
executive director of the Southern New
Hampshire Planning Commission and I was
one of London der's representatives to
that commission but um you have to start
someplace and I think this is a good
place to start we send a lot of money
back to our communities but the one
thing we don't do is we really don't
tell them how do you how you're supposed
to spend this money we leave it up to
them to
decide and this is just one step to just
to say look this is what we're sending
back to you you folks need to have the
conversation about where you think the
money is is best
spent representative yell thank you um
just imagining this this kind of
implementation and how different
municipalities might do this you know
one municipality might might just put um
like a a lottery ticker up in the corner
of their thing that just has the amount
received from the state right where it's
it's not even broken down by the amounts
received just the total sum whereas
others might D list each individual
check that they receive from the state
um you you want that uh to be able to be
that flexible to to be able to comply
with this law to be able to like post it
in any way any manner that they they see
fit thank you representative um I
strongly believe in local control and it
is up to the municipality to decide how
they want to do this um if they start
doing it and they start getting a lot of
feedback from their uh citizens maybe
they can they'll make their own changes
I just don't think that we should be
telling them exactly how to do
this represent
gallager um
so I I'm wondering um so does this apply
just to
um allocations or grants for public
school or does it also apply to um
Charters and education Freedom accounts
it applies to all the money that we send
back to either a school the school
district or the
town if that is included then that's
going to be reported as
well representative
lales thank you Senator Carson
um towns all across the state and all
across the nation quite
frankly uh recently got arpa
funds from the federal
government and it sort of
put Selectmen town
councils what are we going to do with
these and what how can we spend
these and and I know in our particular
case one of the things that we did was
we bought a fire engine that was very
needed MH all right now if you went to
the people of the country and said how
did you spend arpa funds I think a lot
of people would really scratch their
head there was a lot of money that came
from the federal government that was
spent
uh and it was sort of left up to the
local people to to do that so would you
say that in in the case of this
particular Bill you're saying for funds
that are coming from the
state particularly unanticipated funds
some some funds are anticipated but
others are unanticipated mhm yep so
those I I would hope that when we uh
implement this that we we would make
that
differentiation between what is
anticipated what was budgeted for but
then what was kind of extra money all
right and that's extra
money really has the potential of
lowering local property taxes and I
think that's the target it's it's the
money let's say that the state has extra
funds and they bring it they shoot it
back to the towns and we're really
hoping that there there will be some
property tax
relief but if the town doesn't choose to
spend it that way then it doesn't end up
being property tax relief
does that make any sense to you yes
representative I hear exactly what
you're saying and this is the beauty of
our our government the arpa funds came
from the federal government but were
dispersed through the state most
municipalities really didn't know or or
the people how much money their
municipality was getting if this Bill
had been passed they would have known so
it can facilitate a conversation because
now people can see oh we've got so much
money coming into the state whether it's
anticipated or
unanticipated and I'm gonna go out on a
limb here because I'm remembering London
Derry there was a time when we received
unanticipated funds we had to hold a
special meeting to decide how to spend
the that money and I want to say that
there's an RSA that requires that but
I'm not an expert in Municipal law so
please take that with a grain of salt
I'm going to leave that up to you folks
but the point is people will know that
the money is there they've received it
at that point have a conversation with
your community and say what are you
going to spend this money
on because again most people don't even
know they have no clue how much they get
thank you reprentative
Tetra thank you Mr chair thank you
senator for being with us today
um I just have a question on on the
wording where it states that
the uh requiring municipalities and
school governing bodies to I'm sorry
representative I'm sorry I can't hear
you because there's a lot of
construction noise no
really I was going to say be careful
when you go out because you're going to
walk into this huge cloud of dust
outside in a very big machine
um I'll try to speak up
or get in between the
crashes um the it looks to me as
if this the municipality or or School
governing
bodies both get noticed about the money
coming through are the taxpayers and
they both post it are the taxpayers
going to be looking for double the money
because
the town said they got it and the school
district said they got
it thank you for the question
representative I don't believe so um I
think our our folks that are working at
the municipal level will be able to make
that distinction because they're come
the money although it's coming from the
state one's coming through the
Department of Education the other's
coming from the Department of State
whether it's from Transportation HHS or
any other department so I think they're
going to be able to make that dis
iction okay seeing no more hands raised
Senator Carson you are relieved thank
you Mr chairman see I said I thought it
was simple but it wasn't I got a lot of
questions and that's a good thing yeah
that's a good thing very good thank you
all very much for your time this this
afternoon thank you you have two more
cards uh Eric power
hello my name's Eric power again I'm I'm
from Brookline I'm in support of this
bill um I think it's really important
from a transparence transparency
perspective for towns and school
districts to say what money they're
getting I I I'm one of those Hardy Boys
or whatever you okay that goes in looks
at these things in detail um so I know
where to find it but people say how do
you do that and it's actually something
you have to it's a skill but it
shouldn't have to be a skill where you
have to really hunt for things um we get
a lot of money in the town people aren't
aware of it uh I mentioned I I served on
our Co-op School Board I actually
suggested this one time to the school
district at the school board and they
says why can't we tell them we get this
money well people will figure it out
they can read it in the town report and
I'm like well we should make it a little
more prominent I mean as legislators you
do a lot of great work here you pass
budgets it even for yourselves it would
be great to know what's coming from
conquered uh cuz people don't generally
know and this would definitely make it
more prominent um serving on the
planning board in Brookline we've gotten
some grants we got a grant to do a
hydrological study we had another Grant
to do some planning uh for uh for
housing Workforce housing and we had we
people look in this and they say you
guys spent a lot of money but that was a
grant we had gotten from the state and
people just aren't aware they think
we're just spending money that we don't
have but we got this money so you you
know I said yeah we got this as a grant
um and so people aren't aware of that so
um with Esser funds coming into school
districts with arpa funds coming in it
just makes a whole lot of sense to have
this and I I think this is a good first
step I think that you know M
municipalities and school districts will
um implement this the way they want but
I think you know the consumers of it are
going to say if it it doesn't meet their
needs they're probably going to say we
know we want you to break that down a
little more or we' really like to say
what you think you're going to use it on
um but I think just from a transparency
perspective I don't think it's a good
big burden on school districts in towns
to do this and it might even help them
to see you know what money they're
getting and how they're trying to do
their job as the governing bodies of
their towns and school districts so I
think it's a very good bill I would uh
recommend this passage and um I'll take
any
questions thank for your testimony
representative Yella thank you thank you
for taking the question um
so in the last speaker they're like all
about local control and we're going to
be seeing this information kind of
dispersed throughout a bunch of
different websites maybe posted here
posted there um you know if they don't
have a website it seems like that the
all this information is at the state
since the state is paying municipalities
so wouldn't uh
more
uh uh better place to house this
information be on the State website so
that you could see all of the minicipal
all you could break it down and we could
we could break it down as much or as
little as we wanted to and then the
information is just there all in one
place instead of having to hunt andek
and and try and track down what the
method or you know back page that you
know five five links deep on your
Municipal website of where the the money
is actually um getting reported
out that's interesting but you know even
at the state level you have different
organizations getting it and I think
most people the average citizen doesn't
go to the state websites maybe some do
but I don't think that's common but a
lot more people tend to go to their
local municipality website their local
municip it uh the local school district
website so I think you know and they can
present it the way that makes sense
locally um I would rather I would you
know I think that's an interesting idea
that might be something that could be
considered but I do think you know
putting the information down at the
local level makes a lot of sense and if
they wanted to augment it for example as
uh the senator had mentioned they could
augment we got these we got these um
arpa funds and I know in our town I
didn't know this until I asked some
questions they're going to use arpa
funds to buy some voting machines wow no
one knew that just I found that out in
passing but they could augment that at
the local level so if the state had it
they could say they gave us the arpa
funds for you know $30,000 but it
wouldn't be able to be have the
information locally that we're going to
plan on using 25,000 of that for two
voting machines for example so there's
some pluses and minuses there but I
appreciate that
concept further questions
I see none thank you very much for your
testimony Mr PR and one last pink card
uh Mr Christina is back
up thank you again chairman turock good
uh afternoon I guess at this point uh
members of the committee bar Christina
from the New Hampshire Schoolboard
Association um we're not taking a
position on this bill we don't have any
specific objection to it but I just
wanted to highlight to the committee
that um the information that is sought
to be posted on the school district
website is already available in a
multitude of places um it's uh listed in
the annual report the school district
annual report that is required under
both RSA 198 and RSA 32 um the
Department of Education has um a a
program what is called I platform um
every bit of data that school districts
are required to submit is available on
the the the the the state department of
education's website everything from
state aid that's given um to student
Dropout numbers attendance numbers
proficiency scores every bit of data
that that you could possibly want about
your local school district is listed on
that um which is housed and created by
the department of education's um uh on
the department of education's website um
the other thing that I would want to
clarify um as well too is um state
adequacy grants your the money that's
distributed to schools um is distributed
to the school districts four times per
year September 1st November 15th no I'm
sorry uh September 1st um November 1st
January 1st and April 1st as I read the
statute you would have to update your
website those four times a year that's
fine I suppose but the reality is by
October 1st districts know how much
money they're getting for the by
November first I believe it is how much
money they're getting for the for the
course of the year the one question that
I do have Rel and this came up a little
bit with some conversations about some
of the the eser money some of the
federal grants um the language States
the public body shall I'm on line four
shall post the amount of funds received
by the state either through allocation
or Grant is this intended to apply only
to state grants and State money um
school districts receive all sorts of
federal grants special education grants
um other grants from other federal
agencies that you know a school district
might apply for um and it's sort of pass
through money uh uh they may apply
through a special Grant through the
department through the US Department of
Education but that money comes into the
State Department of Education and then
is allocated to the local school
district so that's not State money but
it's being received by the state so just
one clarification on whether or not the
bill is intended to apply to just State
money or money that is federal money but
passed through money that is then moves
on to the the district or the or the
municipality so um in the interest of
transparency absolutely the more
information we can post on our website
and make it easier for for members of
the public to to access and an easy to
read format and not buried on you know
some 10th page that you have to access
that's all well good um but just wanted
to point out that the information is
available in a multitude of other places
um and a multitude of of of other
websites um and the one question I have
about line four and with that happy to
answer any questions that the committee
may have thank you any questions
representative y Kell thank you
um if would it be more clear if it was
just essentially a page on the on the
treasure the New Hampshire treasurer's
website so any check essentially they've
written to the municipality then that
that would be essentially meet the
purpose of this bill without burdening
the municipality right with tracking
down like what who where did this money
officially come from and all of that
kind of stuff um do you think that that
would be a better solution yeah thank
you for the for the question
representative I hadn't contemplated
that till you asked the question to the
to the preview speaker I think that's
certain certainly worth consideration um
there is also another bill I forget the
bill number that was heard in House
Education yesterday that would have
required the district to the school
district to post all sorts of financial
information and data on the school
district's website and one
recommendation that was brought up by a
school superintendent was link your
school I mentioned the I platform that
is that is that is um hosted on the
department of education's website maybe
the district has to post their specific
link the conquered school district will
post the conquered School District data
through the State website on the
conquered School District website I
think that would be perhaps an easier
solution perhaps in line with what
you're talking about representative
rather than you know every month we get
a new Grant in or every four times a
year we got our adequacy Aid in
somebody's got to up update the website
and not that that's a huge lift but it's
another administrative task that we
would be be having to to undergo perhaps
multiple times a
year for the questions I have one you
hit on an uh an area I had a question on
and that is federal funding M does let's
say a school
district any federal money goes through
the state not directly to the school
correct correct okay yes thank you
further
questions seeing none thank you very
very much for Testimony I have no more I
have one pink card on the way Miss heck
is going to come up and
speak good afternoon members of the
committee Mr chairman for the record my
name is Katherine heck and I represent
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
in the 234 cities and towns in New
Hampshire and I apologize that I was
unable to hear prior testimony or if I
am redundant please feel free to stop me
so I can be brief could you pull that
mic a little close to your mouth please
thank you yes of course so feel free to
stop me if anything is being repeated
that you've already heard I don't want
to waste anybody's time um I had met
with the sponsor of the the bill
originally in the summer who was looking
for some clarity around when cities and
towns and schools receive their funds
versus when they are reported to the
public um we did go through all the
different various documents that towns
would provide to their taxpayers so that
they do see these funds so the Dr Ms 636
for example contains all state aid
federal grants um any one-time payments
that report um is filed with the state
but of course it is filed um at a
certain point in the year we also have
our annual report as you've all seen in
your own communities that's required by
law and the funds would be reported
there as well um the LBA the legislative
budget assistant will also do a report
that is broken down not only in the
large amount of money the overall
allocation provided to cities and towns
but they will break every Grant down on
their website usually about seven months
later after the budget passes for
example or they update it usually in May
of every year and every single community
that receives funding it will be broken
down so while we can see the funding in
various places it is not reported
quickly so when you all pass the budget
and we receive funding or perhaps you
have given us a one-time payment which
we've seen quite a bit of one-time
funding I'll give you a very specific
example the highway block grant we
receive four payments a year from the
state it's reported in our annual report
it's also reported in um our Dr report
so they can be found in both places as
well as the LBA however when you gave us
the one-time payments we
you voted in May the end of May to
approve the budget we had the onetime
funding and we didn't find out our
allocations until just the following
December we so we could kind of have
estimates but we didn't have those
dollar amounts till December so they may
or may not um depending on timing even
make it into that annual report just
based on when the state decides that
it's going to release the funding meals
and rooms is another great example we
have benefited greatly from the new
formula that you have all approved and
we thank you very much for that but we
do not know until we set the tax rate
what the meals and rooms amount will be
so it's the state treasurer provides the
number to the Dr and by October 1st but
cities and towns until they call the Dr
to set their tax rate are not made aware
of what that number is the report is
then put on the treasurer's website once
all tax rates are set so towns don't
have this information in advance so this
was a compromise with the sponsor
so that when we do become aware of these
dollars whatever they are that we can
then report them to the public on on the
website or in a newspaper if no website
is available so I hope that gives you a
little background as to how we how we
got here thank you uh from your
testimony I'm assuming the nhma is in
favor of this you didn't say from the
beginning so we are we are neutral
neutal on the bill um thank
you questions representative Hicks thank
you Mr chairman um thank you you for
taking the question would it do you
think in your it would
be could you pull that mic a little
closer to you please do you think it
would be um better for
municipalities to add something into
this bill that might
say online for
um body shall
post or provide a link to the amount of
funds per um representative y Kell's
comments about linking to other websites
oh and I apologize I I didn't hear I I
think that could be a a great suggestion
because there are plenty of other places
Dees for example when we get a grant if
it's a specific Grant to a municipality
that will be on their website do there's
so many places this information exists
um and I think the sponsor's intent for
my understanding and I don't wish to put
words in anyone's mouth is to make sure
that the taxpayers and the public knew
when you are vote to give us money that
they were able to see it in closer to
real time to when we're receiving it I
think that was the intent of the bill so
I think a link um could could be
appropriate as well it's whatever you
see fit other states actually have a
State website where you can put in the
town and it's updated regularly and I
have examples of that it's called the
cherry sheet for example in our
neighbors to the South um so you can see
constantly what what new Aid might be
coming into a community but this is a
different way um that we would be
handling it here in New Hampshire a
different way to solve the same
issue further questions comments
representative thank you um the sheet
that you were just mentioning
um cherry cherry sheet yes yeah um is
that if you know do you know if that is
uh maintained by the state treasurer on
on the state treasurer's website or is
it its own dedicated website how how was
that
um administered I I believe it's their
budget office that that handles it and
they they compile the information coming
from the different places but I'm happy
to I I have a copy I'll give it to you
Connecticut has several states have it
and we and we do maintain this the LBA
will update it every May and October so
we can go to the lb's website and get
get these documents broken down by
Community or by school district with the
aid provided to them but it's only
updated twice a year like our annual
reports are updated once a year so I
think this was looking to solve a a
different um a different
concern further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank I have no more pink
cards uh with that we will close the
hearing on SP
532 okay
um our next hearing is at 1:00 sorry
everybody that we're not going to get an
hour but 1:00 um also before everybody
gets up and leaves if you um next
Tuesday I I hope everybody got the email
talking about we we're going to have two
more uh bills that we need to have
hearings on and I'll plan on that time
uh executing the bills that we heard
today represent PR um I'll get after I
figure out the timing of it I got to go
talk with Jamie right now and work that
out but Pro most likely 10:00 again
maybe
9:30 um and that's it we'll see you back
here at
e
e e
what what's interesting is all these
Waters from all over the world they all
taste exactly the
same they're they're all filtered
they're all you
know e
okay um it is 1:15 I'm not sure where
the senator is but we do need to kind of
get going here um just so
everybody's in the room uh we will uh
hear two bills next Tuesday beginning at
9:30 we are going to start at 9:30 and
then we're going to uh have all of the
bills we did today plus at least one of
the two next week we're going to have to
exec because it's we just found out it's
an early bill
so uh we will be doing that yes
representative
kill um we'll give we'll give the
senator another two or three minutes and
then yes you can do
that 23rd
just under the gun Senator
representative
Brown okay we'll go ahead and open up uh
Senate bille 491 I see the so sponsor
Senator Bradley is here it is your floor
Senator
Bradley and before the senator starts uh
we have a blue sheet with four people
who signed up we only have one pink card
so if you intend to speak that needs to
uh you need to fill one out Senator
Bradley go ahead uh good afternoon
Representative turot members of the
committee um pleased to be here um here
on behalf of a constituent request and
he is here could you do one thing for me
introduce myself no no pull pull the mic
a little closer to you s hear you so um
I should introduce myself first sorry
about that um Jeb Bradley from wolfboro
here as the sponsor of Senate Bill 491
and I apologize for being a few minutes
late we weren't sure when you were folks
were coming back so thank you for your
forbearance um this is a constituent
request that came as a result of um an
issue in the town of
Wakefield
um it deals with private road agreements
and the bill is trying to make clear
that municipalities may enter into
agreements to maintain a private road
without having to be
responsible um for the long-term
obligation of upgra upgrading that road
so I think um as you will hear from my
constituent there was some concern about
um on one of the lakes in Wakefield Road
not being maintained the impact on water
quality and the town apparently was Will
only to maintain it but the status of
the law if they start maintaining it
then they are
responsible um for the long-term upkeep
of it so the bill continues to say that
a municipality has to be responsible for
getting the written consent of every
owner um and it would have to be in
clear um language as to what they were
trying to do and the Department of
Transportation adopt rues so hopefully a
very simple Bill and um thank you very
much represent of power question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you president
Bradley for taking my question so I I
may be a little confused um I thought
that I heard that you say that the
purpose of this was this bill was with
regards to maintaining the road however
in line four that I see that it says
that the the agreement pertains to
allowing the municipality to use the
road and and that um was how the senate
committee amended it and I think that
was fine with the um my
constituent but it further says in the
end of line four to five it does not
obligate the municipality to maintain
the road so that that is the
point hopefully did you have
a if you have a yes follow follow up go
ahead so so I do see that the the um
agreement is with regard to the use of
the road and then it says further lines
four and five that the agreement shall
not obligate the municipality to
maintain the road that's correct however
is there um the ability for that
agreement
perhaps if the roads being used could
there be a mutual agreement that the
municipality might also maintain the
road and that is it it just as I
understand it it would allow more
flexibility in the case that there you
know is
um some issue on a private road that the
town for whatever reason in an agreement
with the property owners would maintain
it because of maybe through traffic
maybe an impact on a water body
something like that but it would not
commit the town to a long-term
obligation representative stavis did you
have a question uh yes and it's actually
a followup on representative Powers
question I understand that this is an
amended version of the bill to utilize
the word use the road instead of
maintain the road but how um will
future legislative bodies in
municipalities be able to differentiate
between maintenance and use those are
two very different
things I think what words here mean
everything and I wonder if you'd agree
with that and you know what I think um
I'm going to let Mr Robbins my
constituent from Wakefield try to answer
that because he's the one that brought
this to
me representative y
Kell thank you uh thank you for taking
the question so it seems like the the
way youve presented this bill to us is
that somewhere in statute essentially if
you start maintaining a road then the
municipality is on the hook forever
however this is a new section of Law and
it's not
actually repealing and replacing some
existing that existing requirement um so
one I'm wondering where that requirement
exists in the law and two um
does
this it's it's not clear that this
exempts from that other section of law
if if that other section of law exists
so not sure I can answer the other
section of law question but just based
on what the situation was in the town I
represent um this was intended to fix
that so that the town would be able to
um on a temporary
basis help
a private road without a long-term
obligation representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman thank you
Senator so I'm familiar with some some
uh things in my town of molten beer
which they're they're trying to do along
these same lines so I've spoken to my
Selectmen about several of these issues
over the last couple years but to me it
seems like the the item that uh really
controls this is the fact that this is a
contract so there's a limited term to
this contract for use of the road and
for maintenance of the road and also
that the fact the fact is that when they
enter into the contract it would
determine who is going to maintain that
road in for what time period am I
correcting that assumption
um I think you've probably done a pretty
good job of explaining one potential
option that this would allow without
that long-term maintenance yes okay
thank you followup Mr chairman go ahead
so the follow-up question in regard to
this is that uh also concer in that I
want to make sure I understand is it
says that the commissioner of the
Department of Transportation shall adopt
rules for two to the RSA governing this
Law's requirement so um have you worked
with the Department of Transportation
and tried to understand what this is or
is there any kind of guidance that or
did they testify in regard to this I
don't Rec that they testified in regard
to this in this okay thanks Senator
yep representative
majori thank you Mr chairman and thank
you senator for taking my question uh if
there's change in ownership on the
property is that left to the discretion
of or is that left to the discretion of
however the agreement was written or
does that make the agreement null and
void in your
opinion
so on line four it's pretty explicit the
municipality shall be responsible for
obtaining the written consent of every
owner of the road and so I would
interpret that to mean regardless of any
change in ownership if there were any
kind of
ongoing um you know commitments or
issues representative Elward yes thank
you Mr chairman thank you Senator um I
have the same concern as to to where
this contract would be you know
archived I'm
wondering if it should be uh registered
with the registry of deeds should it be
an attachment this contract an
attachment to the
um agreement written agreement I mean I
I just and I also
wonder
obligating um Private Road owners
[Music]
to something that we haven't um seen the
rules you know from do what that would
be about so can you expound on that at
all
so in terms of registering it with the
um registry of deeds I'm not sure that's
necessary but you know I'm open to that
discussion um and in terms of the the
second part of your
question as this was brought to me um it
was meant to be temporary and
so
um again I think that
the protection for the property owners
is there and that they would have to
agree um with the
municipality um doing whatever they
would do on a short term
basis
follow yes sir
um I don't read temporary in here whatso
I I I understand that um
but that's how it was explained to me
okay I get it thank
you representative
FR thank you Mr chair um my question
would
be if a Town enters into an agreement
with a land Owners Association to do
work on a private road would the town
then assume the liability for any damage
that they did or would that
maintain would that liability still lie
with the road maintenance
Association thank you I'm not sure that
I could answer that I mean this is meant
to be
enabling um for towns to be able to
cooperate with private road owners if
there's a situation where both
sides need to take action so long-term
implications I'm not sure I can answer
because we haven't seen
it representative
stavis uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I understand
that you don't have a lot of details
about the bill but I have um some
hypothetic
questions I would imagine that
homeowners on private roads would flock
to this would it become law because
everybody needs to have their Road
maintained and it cost tens of thousands
of dollars to do so a and if if a New
Hampshire law exists that allows
municipalities to enter into such
agreements I would imagine that many
homeowners on private roads would want
such
agreements where is the fairness in that
to those me homeowners on private roads
who may not be able to convince their
legislative bodies to enter into such
agreements but maybe their neighbors on
another private road have managed to
convince their municipalities to do so
um it seems to me that there are two
categories of roads in New Hampshire
those maintained by the municipality and
those that aren't
and those roads don't meet so to speak
so again I think this is meant to be
enabling for those circumstances where
there is agreement
between um a municipality because it
says may doesn't say shall it says may
and an agreement has to um be signed by
every road every owner um on the road
so Private Road owners go before Town
meetings all the time trying to get the
town to take over the long-term
obligations on that road and make it a
town own Road I mean that happens
virtually at every town meeting and the
whatever the legislative body is has to
make a decision whether it should or
shouldn't happen this is as I understand
it would allow some maybe more
short-term option um that wouldn't
obligate a
long-term um situ
ation to
repair
use a road that
needed that kind of assistance and
property owners that it would benefit
both sides the town and the property
owners that
um as I understand it doesn't exist in
law today so um you know you're asking a
lot of questions I'm sorry I don't have
every answer for that it it is a
constituent request because it was was a
real situation that occurred in
Wakefield and my constituent Mr Robbins
can probably walk you through exactly
what happened and why you know in the
situation in the town of Wakefield he
has felt it's
necessary further questions for
Senator seeing none thank you very much
um is there anybody else that plan to
testify on this you need to pill out a
pink card sir over
there okay just put your name and every
and bring it up to up to
me just so we know who you are and we
have a record of
it I'll tell you what go you can go
testify and then fill it out before you
leave how's that I thought you had
already filled it up okay
so what I'm going to ask you to do is
first turn on the mic
uh explain who you are I'm assuming
you're in favor of this and then give us
your testim the right button press it
down and just release it there you go
pull it close to you so we can hear you
almost like I know what I'm doing pull
pull the mic closer to you because we're
not going to be able to hear you push
this closer
you're the first person who said they
couldn't hand me in my life but go ahead
okay yes um I brought this to Senator
Bradley about a year and a half ago and
obviously last year's legislature you
fill hold on one sec let us know who you
are your name excuse me where you're
from and I whether you're for or against
the bill okay it's uh Chuck or Charles
Robbins from Wakefield New
Hampshire and um I'm Father Bill I'm the
Catalyst behind this being here today
and I spoke in front of the Senate back
on uh February 6 committee and they were
helpful and Senator gray was great he
was the one who put
the um amendment in to add legislative
bodies the first language so that us the
town people would vote on it and put it
into our um zoning ordinance and the
purpose of it is for years since 1984 i'
like all of you we've uh swam in the New
Hampshire Lake since we were born but
since 1984 I've sent out letters in my
town to uh for the different lakes and
I've watched uh what's going on with the
Lakes back in the 80s we were concerned
mainly with sewage and uh that was a big
point and there was 13 points that the
dees sent out uh don't feed the Ducks
because they'll have more than one
litter so there were many points don't
use colored toilet paper paper things
like that I got phone calls over that
one but uh over the years the bigger
problem obviously when we all were kids
we all went swimming in these lakes and
we probably used soap because no one had
showers nobody had washing machines no
one was if you had a 55 gallon drum that
might have been your septic system so
people use them as camps so the impact
over the years has been that people are
spending a lot more time there as we all
know getting a lot of knockdowns in new
homes with new septic systems but still
the impact but the big thing that I've
learned over the years is um and my
background is Development I've done gas
stations Billboards housing subdivisions
so I have some excavation knowledge for
dirt work but over the years I wasn't
really that sharp until probably 7 eight
10 years ago that all this gravel that
we're bringing into these private roads
every year and sometimes roads but
mostly private we have 50 miles of Roads
around uh shorefront in Wakefield so
every year we bring gravel in and I was
made aware it's filled with nutrients so
these nutrients as it disappears it ends
up in the Lakes what it's doing is we
you've all heard about Caceria and
that's everywhere now and the biggest
thing that we're missing is one of these
results is dissolved oxygen the bre
breathable air in these Lakes for The
Aquatic Life is disappearing I'll give
you two examples of our 678 lakes in
Wakefield could you hold on just one
second no up front up here
chairman right could you try to speak to
the subject matter of the bill the bill
is whether or not a town is going to
maintain a private road or not great all
the the the other stuff you're talking
about really doesn't apply we need to
hear why great so the reason so that
that's a good place for me to stop then
so all this gravel that I'm talking
about we have to find an alternative we
have to control that erosion that's
going into the Lakes now the rules that
the Supreme Court has ruled down if you
even go in and plow these private roads
you may be held
responsible so when I proposed this to
the town a couple years ago that was one
of the concerns of one of my Selectmen
we've had cits blow out on these roads
and because the covits blew out we've
had to go in and deal with it well the
town's been very afraid to deal with
even replacing a covet that's stopping
people from getting to their homes
because they don't want to take
ownership of the
road so that's what this is coming from
is the fact that these roads have to be
maintained but the towns don't want them
someday if all the people who live in
town vote to take a road over that'll be
different but until then most towns
don't want to own these private roads
and this is I'm specifically talking
about Lakes you people may have heard
about other towns that have private
roads not near lakes and that's a big
issue too I'm sure but in order for the
town to go in and work on these Lakes
not have to take the responsibility of
them I'm a real estate guy you can make
a deal you can write out the specifics
in that contract for the year
2024 we're going to go into Lake Road
and we're going to work from this point
to this point
and we're going to perform these duties
and both parties agree the landowner who
would be the road owner if there's
multiple you'll have to get everybody to
sign off on it and the
municipality spelled out in here would
be no responsibility to the municipality
beyond what they're saying they're going
to go in and then wake field just as an
example why this is so important and
it's a reflection to the rest of the
state we are
70.8% almost 71%
of our total revenue comes off of these
Lakes we we spend very little to protect
them and and 2016 I fought to get a
shorel officer in one of the first if
not the first in the state because the
dees is way overstretched they have one
guy taking care of multiple Lakes it's
just and we don't have any enforcement
so if there's any questions I'm sure
I've talked more than I should have but
go
ahead representative we'll start over
there representative priest go ahead
thank you Mr chairman uh and thank you
for being here um if the town goes in
and makes the
necessary uh
improvements uh for your private road
will they then come back to you and
assess you for the work that they have
done assess who assess who assess the
property owners that are getting the
benefits from the road uh improvements I
think that's a reflection of the sale
price and in Wakefield we do every five
years sometimes do every year but if if
that if anything done is done to a
property if you have a better view or
anything you'll be assessed for what the
assessor perceives as an improvement I
would
assume representative y
Kell thank you thank you for uh your
testimony
um since since uh you referenced this uh
Supreme Court decision are you famili
can you um tell me what the the Supreme
Court decision uh the name of it was and
or the the law that they were basing
that that
uh I left that package on the car I've
had it for years in my pocket I wish I
could give you the
number I mean you could follow up
Supreme well I could follow up with you
yeah but the Supreme Court has
constantly ruled that town should stay
away from any type of financial or
physical involvement in working on
private roads with as little as and that
that one big case was about snow plowing
which we would think would be pretty
innocuous but just because they were
snow plowing that road the state said uh
the Supreme Court ruled you're working
on that road you're accepting
responsibility so that's what we're
trying to
avoid representative
Elwood all right so thank you Mr
chairman um yes statute does say I think
uh if you plow if the town maintains or
repairs a private road
within I think it's five years if they
do it continually for five years that
they're then obligated uh to continue
maintaining the road
how
would the town be
compensated for doing plowing repair or
maintenance on the road well I I think
that the point is in Wakefield we have
a$2 million budget and as I said 14
million of it's coming from there 90% or
better of the people paying those tax
bills do not live there year round so we
don't have school children from them we
don't have public services dump police
fire higher at the same rate as a
citizen so for us we have a 685 tax rate
we're the cheapest town in the state of
New Hampshire for any town with more
than 4,000
population 5,000 excuse me 5,000 molor
has 4,300 and they're cheaper but
Wakefield is it's unbelievable to live
there I live on the Milton Mills Town
Line my house is
4,200 the same house over the line would
probably be 11 or 12 Grand and that's
reflect of Rochester DOA probably the
towns over here um so the benefit to
these lakes and the overall benefit to
the state of New Hampshire people are
coming here for clean Lakes not cob
bacteria
Laden go ahead sorry man go
ahead representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for taking my question and I am the rep
one of the representatives from molor so
I know what you're talking about so
anyway um I guess one of the things I
I'd want to ask you about is you know
this is a temporary contract but also
have you reviewed this with your
selectman and is this something that
they've said they want to do well what
happened was because I'm always in there
pushing the legs I I did a survey in
20121 on this specifically on working on
private roads and putting a crew
together and I got a five to one
response and you had to give me your
name address and what you thought it
wasn't Anonymous so when you get a 5:1
response I brought that into selectman I
brought that survey in and showed them
that ta taxpayers are willing but the
one of the
selectman you know smartly brought this
point up I said I'm a real estate guy I
can you can make a contract with anyone
you don't need the state law was my
belief you should be able they still
would be more comfortable if the state
would back them up and say we make a
contract with someone that's usually
legally binding at least the state's not
going to and the Supreme Court's not
going to tell us
do we have to take the road over
followup Mr
chairman so the the question I have then
in regard to this is what would prevent
the town or the property owners uh in
Wakefield from saying okay you fixed my
road this year you took care of the
covits this year I'm real happy then six
years later five years later they want
to do another contract to maintain their
Road
basically I think both like any contract
and any deal that you're do in life both
parties have to be willing to sign on to
that thank
you representative kill thank you Mr
chair I'm over here sir thank you for
taking my question um is your town
currently maintaining your road plowing
anything like that no none of our we
stay away from it as I say we have 50
miles of shorefront so we have almost
matching amount of roads and most of all
of them are private so the town has been
very aware that you don't go near those
roads follow up go ahead I I was
referring to your your individual your
road are you on a private road sir I
have my home where I live I'm on a
regular Town Road I just four years ago
bought on a Camp Road and I had landed
on a Camp Road for years before that but
I've
never I'm on a Camp Road where the
people really take care of the road they
do a Monster job they do as well as any
municipality could but they bring in
gravel they grade it the gravel goes in
the lake and therefore New Hampshire's
losing this valuable tax
revenue further questions representative
majori thank you Mr chairman um this
question may be getting too far into the
weeds I'm not really sure but if the
private road has been recognized by the
planning board then the municipality can
make it the governing body can make a
decision about whether or not they're
going to accept that as a dedicated Road
in this
instance what I'm concerned about is if
the road has not been recognized by the
planning board in order for this road to
be recognized by the municipality it
needs legislative body approval a
warrant article so I'm I'm wondering if
we have gotten so if I'm getting so far
into the weeds where you have
contemplated whether or not that
contract would have to go before the
legislative body as a warrant article
for approval
well I think I think that what Senator
gray added in his addendum the first uh
line legislative bodies of the
municipality may enter into agreements I
think that that was a sharp thing that
he gave me on the senate committee
meeting but uh you know private roads
are a big thing but for a town like
Wakefield when you're talking almost 71%
of its income you bet I mean if if a
company comes to your town or your state
and says I'm going to employ a th000 or
a 100,000 for the state most communities
they give them five years of free taxes
they bend over backwards when you bring
that type of Revenue in that's what
these Lakes are they're a huge Revenue
driver for the state thank you
sir all right further question represent
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question here oh hi
um when I first read this and I saw the
word
use um my impression and that it's just
what came to my mind was Municipal
trucks or or Vehicles passing through on
a privately owned Road not anything
about constructing a road or maintaining
a road just using it like you use any
street is that um
is use maybe the wrong word well I think
that the the key here is no work is
going to be done until there's a written
contract between the owner of the
road and the municipality so like you
said we can go in and look at different
parts here but this is just giving the
town the the ability to enter into a
contract with a landowner which they
could do now but my Selectmen who
brought it up wanted the backing of the
state to say just because we're in there
working on the road and we have a valid
contract with the road owner we do not
have to accept this as the Supreme Court
has ruled even with plowing and as
representative over there mentioned
earlier the repetitive helping of people
on the road may end up having you own
the road specifically you would not be
entering into anything like that with a
written
contract representative El
thank you Mr chairman just real quick
sir sir I I'm listening oh okay um my
question is did a land use
attorney weigh in on this did who a land
use attorney did you have a land use
attorney look at this and and give you
advice well I have a land use attorney
that I've had for years I'm done this 45
48 years I've lived eat and breathed
development uhhuh so I respect attorneys
who've done Municipal law very much and
I read the the the uh Municipal findings
that come but I do these type of
contracts my whole life so I'm very
versed in how I picture this would
happen thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you than you
very much for your testimony thanks for
your patience guys I really appreciate
it okay I don't have any more pink cards
on this bill so with that uh we'll close
the hearing on S SP
491 we will give the clerk just a minute
or two and we will move on to our final
bill of the
day
e e
okay Mr clerk you set all right very
good uh we'll go ahead and open up the
hearing now on Senate
bill Senate Bill 383 relative to local
tax caps and Senator Murphy is prime
sponsor you are up thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee it's a pleasure
to be back in front of my friends in the
house um
this bill Keith Murphy representing the
towns of Raymond Candia hookit Goffstown
and Manchester's First Ward this bill is
enabling legislation allowing uh another
method of calculating a tax cap for
communities that choose to adopt it um
it does add another method for school
districts to impl a tax cap it
essentially
allows the same methods for towns that
are currently allowed for cities
um uh and the committee amendment that
we adopted over over in the Senate uh
address some issues that were brought to
our attention during the hearing by the
municipal Association um I have with me
in the interest of efficiency Mr
chairman representative uh McGuire he is
a co-sponsor and I think is very uh
prepared to speak on the bill as
well thank you so um yeah representative
Dan Maguire I represent the town of epom
so when we what this bill does is it
modifies RSA uh 32 colon 5
which is an existing um form of tax cap
uh in our law for towns but it's but
it's um not used very much because it's
really poorly written so this is a bill
to make it more practical um as you as
you're probably aware many cities like
Manchester nsha
Franklin have tax caps of of various
sorts as part of their
um Charters and
um RSA 32 colon 5 allows towns um to
have similar sort of tax caps the
problem is the way it's written those
are those tax caps don't really work
very well because because the language
in in 32 colon 5 says you can have one
of two kinds of tax caps you can have it
such that the amount for next year is a
fixed dollar amount more than this year
right so if your budget is a million
this year and your tax cap says $50,000
then next year you you your budget could
be a million 50,000 right or the RSA
allows you to have a fixed percentage
right like your your budget can go up by
2% per year something like that the
problem is you know reality is not fixed
numbers or fixed percentages right
reality with inflation is well this year
it's very high next year it's not so
high and so on plus the fact that
districts or you know the the population
of those districts changes per year also
right so some towns um are growing their
population very rapidly presumably they
you know their services would have to
change more quickly than other places
where the population isn't changing very
rapidly and so what this bill does does
is it allows towns to have a tax
cap similar to what cities now do which
is the cap can move year toe based on
population change times an inflation
Factor okay so that's a practical tax
cap not like the ones the ones in here
and the the bill um allows these caps to
to be placed by school districts and or
by towns right so on the town part of
the budget or on the the school district
part and um there's details but but
basically the um the adoption of such a
cap and or the deletion of such a cap
would be done by a 60% vote three fifths
or overriding such a cap would be a
35ths vote so so you need a super
majority to put it in place you need a
super majority to take it away
super majority change it but once it's
in place um towns or school districts
would have to follow these caps and um
representative power asked me to mention
we have um she and I have a small
amendment that um has to do with the
timing of uh School District budgeting
right so the the way the school district
budgeting you know what happens this
year and next year and so on um in the
bill doesn't quite match what
they actually do and so this this
amendment fixes that I think and we're
happy to answer
questions questions representative
lales yes thank you for uh bringing this
and this has been needed quite a while
uh you know fixed
amounts and percentages when inflation
goes like this I mean we've seen the
impact of that in the recent times with
all the impacts of inflation and so
forth my question is some towns don't
have tax caps they have spending
caps now does this bill impact spending
caps in the same way that you talk about
tax
gaps I can answer yeah so it's it's sort
of a technical thing but but the way
this is written is that on towns it's a
tax cap so it's the it's the actual tax
amount for the municipality on school
districts it's a spending cap it's a
it's the amount they're spending because
because they have Revenue so towns
almost have much more sort of known
Revenue right whereas school districts
some years they get a grant some years
they don't and all that sort of things
so so on school districts it's a
spending cap on towns it's a tax
G representative yella go ahead thank
you thank you for taking the question
um you said
that there is or at least you indicated
that there was very few but you didn't
specifically say that no municipality
currently has this um setup and so my
question to you is if municipalities
already have this set up um would you be
essentially barring them from the their
how they have it currently and if this
changes kind of like we when we change
you know um uh the law regarding
exemptions they have to reopt it um
which may or may not be um easy I'm
wondering about the people that are
currently under a c tax cap will they
have to reopt and will they have to
adopt this new structure or are they
able to be grandfathered in if they like
their structure can they keep it uh yes
thank you for the question
representative and the answer is yes
this does not affect existing um there
there's a handful the I I I think
there's three maybe or four I have the
list somewhere yeah 10 yeah whatever
there's a small number but um the
biggest one is dairy in fact um and um
but if you look on page
two um line
one so the tax so we're just adding the
word multipli multiplication Factor so
you so the tax cap can be a fixed amount
a fixed percentage or a multiplication
Factor right so this is a new thing that
they can adopt if they want to but
presumably the way they would change if
they already had a fixed dollar amount
and wanted a multiplication Factor they
would have a two a three- fif vote to
you know make a change like that
yeah represent power thank you Mr
chairman I have two points of
clarification so the first would be that
this I see three sections in this bill
the first um section is pertains to a
local tax cap and I I just just would
like to clarify um that it does pertain
to both towns as well as school
districts and I know that to be true
because my um Brookline School District
has a local tax
cap and um with regards to section two
that's a school district Bud well the
first one's a tax effort cap with
regards to section two the School
District budget cap is is a spending cap
and that that would be new legislation
that doesn't already exist and the third
point of clarification is that um the
bill when drafted was wisely put in
section three which pertains to
applicability and it says that with
regards to the local tax caps previously
in place it does not require local reopt
and it would not pertain to section two
of School District budget caps because
that is not in our
statute we agree
do you have a response to that question
I'm kidding I think that's all correct
it wasn't any question we agree further
questions representative lales your
mic's still on you have a question
nope uh representative major thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious about the
calculator if if that is a a new
calculator that that you created or if
it has if it has some proven effects
somewhere just just curious about the
origins of the T of the
calculator are you asking about um in
1ba just 1ba yeah so I I I I'm sort of
looking at um or page two line 19 for oh
sorry yeah I should uh so page I guess
that would be sorry page two lines lines
13 through 17 so the way you come up
with that calculation is that based on
some best practice or is that is that
and and please forgive the word a new
invention I don't mean invention in a
derogatory way no I think this is very
similar to what cities do okay okay and
there are some details here like for
example on line 20 where we had the
municipal cost index so that this
language is fairly flexible it allows a
a a school district or or a municipality
to choose the inflation index that they
want it doesn't have to be CPI it could
be this one also listed here Municipal
cost index that's one the municipal
Association asked us to add because
because there are a few different
inflation indices and uh some may be
more appropriate to Municipal expenses
and and costs and others to you know
different kinds of costs so so the P the
organiz that makes the Warren article to
adopt it would would make a decision we
want the such and such you know the CPI
or the MCI or whichever index they
want yeah representative stavis uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question which I will desperately try to
articulate in a way that makes sense I'm
looking uh at page
one line
well the section section
four
um under subsection
1B which pertains to population figures
and it's lines 28 29 and 30 population
shall mean the population figures
calculated by the Department of Business
and economic Affairs office of Planning
and Development pursuant RSA 78 a25
Roman numeral 3 and as I read 78 a25
Roman numeral 3 I see some potential
pitfalls that I have questions about and
they have to do with the dates by which
this information is
gathered uh and the um opportunities for
municipalities to appeal the numbers
they get from planning if they disagree
with those numbers now in the middle of
all of this estimating and repor repor
in on the preceding Year's population
which is what planning reports
on how does that mesh with the need to
set up an an annual
budget in a municipality is there is
there are there potential timing
problems there that that need to be
addressed right thank you for the
question representative I I guess I
would say that you have to pick a date
right and and
um it's going to be you know this this
is going to be a date that that works
annually right so so if you're off by
one year in some sense it's I I don't
see that as a as a huge tragedy um but
we asked the drafters to just give us
where is in law the existing sort of
standard place where um where
populations are are referenced right and
that's this spot so
um I guess I don't have a a better
answer for you
but I would just also if I may chime in
that um page two line B you know it
revers that multiplication factor and
towns can adjust for that with the
multiplication
factor a town growing or shrinking if
you really believe that one year is
making a huge difference they can adjust
for that the multiplication Factor I'm
sorry I didn't hear that last part if a
town is shrinking at 1% a year or 2% a
year or 3% a year shrinking or growing
they can adjust the multiplication
Factor when they adopt the tax cap they
can take that into account at the
time thank
you further questions
comments I have two very easy ones
hopefully um in
your formula you have the inflation one
plus the inflation
Factor Why is the one there what's the
purpose of
that yeah so so let's say the cap is a
million dollars and inflation is
2% right you want
1.02 times the million dollars is your
new limit right your new limit is a
million
$20,000 right if you see what I mean so
the one is is the existing plus the
difference right and the inflation is
the
difference I think I was misreading it I
thought I thought what you were getting
at it is it could be inflation FL Factor
plus an additional 1% you're no no no I
got you never mind all right uh second
question uh on line 19 page two you kind
of touched on it uh you can use one of
two inflation
indexes um it's actually more than two
so the first thing where it says hold on
hold on hold on hold on I'm sorry
um but what got me is the word either
why uh and I know you mentioned the nhma
suggested one of the
two uh but why either why why are you
getting away from consistency in that
regard this thank you for the question
but this is this is flexibility for for
town to make a choice right so so I
believe that the US Bureau of Labor
Statistics has multiple inflation indes
sees right they have CPI Dash something
rather urban and rural and different
things right so so the people that adopt
this can can choose one of those or this
other one the municipal cost index Etc
right
so they're all relatively similar but
but as I understand it the municipal
cost index
includes the CPI is more or less
um uh an index based on uh salaries and
and labor and that kind of thing
mostly um and that's you know that's
reasonable because most government
expenses are for salaries but but the
municipal cost index includes some
construction factors right so so it it
it um you know if you need to build
every once in a while you build a new
school or a new building you know that's
and and roads are obviously construction
so so you know they may argue that
that's a better
index they're they're not that different
right so basically I guess my basic
question is why the choice but you're
agnostic to what which one they pick
that's absolutely good it's it's the
people doing it are going to have to
make their own Arguments for it right
and so let them pick what they want very
good represent power thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question on page three SE Roman numeral
section 4 is it true that um these fine
details will be specified in the the
question that will appear on the warrant
as to um what the School District budget
cap is going to look like um regarding
like the picking and choosing of what
the formula is going to be it will be
all specified and laid out right there
um in the Warren
article
yes
yes further
questions represent
fre thank you so much and and thank you
for both of you for being here um on
this tax cap I'm just curious was there
a municipality or town that came to you
and was in qu itive about doing this was
there a
problem somewhere in the state that
you're seeking to address or did you
just think that this would be a good way
to address this flaw in the current
statutes speaking for myself I did hear
from a constituent who was concerned
that his town and I won't give you the
name of the town because I don't want to
get this person cause him any issues but
he was frustrated that his talent was
not allowing him to adopt a uh school um
uh spending cap in the manner that um
they could adopt a municipal tax cap um
and I'll leave Senator representative
McGuire answer his question yeah I mean
my own constituents are uh very strongly
in um needing and asking for something
like this because I mean our our
property tax bill our school our town is
great I mean they they they're flat
funded this particular particular year
but my school is spending 10% more you
know I mean it's just amazing and uh so
my overall property tax is going to be
going up 8% this year right so that's
that's people are are very very in favor
of this kind of
thing further
questions seeing none thank you
gentlemen for your testimony I apologize
I can't stay my committee's meeting for
over there
okay next pink card I have uh Mr
Christina frequent frequent uh flyer
today with
us thank you again chairman turock good
afternoon members of the of the
committee barer Christina for the New
Hampshire school boards Association um
we're opposed to the bill just to be
clear we're not opposed to tax caps uh
we believe that that should be left into
the hands of of local voters the
concerns that nhba has with the bill is
that under current law a school district
can adopt either a tax cap or a spending
cap the law allows them to F to select
the voters to select either a fixed
dollar amount or a fixed percentage as
I'm reading the bill if a school
district does not currently have a tax
cap but wanted to implement one they
would be tied to this particular formula
nhba believes that the voters should be
able to choose what number or what
percentage that they necessarily want
rather than being tied down to a to a
particular statutory to a statuto
formula um second um my understanding my
research I could be wrong on this but I
believe there's only three school
districts and not counting the cities I
should say only three school districts
non- cities that have adopted local tax
caps so I understand that the
representative and the senator said
they've heard this from constituents but
this room isn't filled with people
people clamoring for a new method or a
new version of a particular tax cap um
so you know we we question the I believe
the representative over here asked what
was sort of the impetus for this and I
understand that it's often a constituent
that asked for the bill to be put in but
you know there doesn't seem to be a
Statewide desire to change what what
voters have been able to do for a number
of years um the other aspects uh
concerns that we have I believe it's
on
page uh I
apologize I believe it's on page two
line 32 and
33 um about uh the bonding issues and if
if you have a bond that only the first
year payment on the bond is going to be
um calculated in the tax cap your firste
bond payment is often lower than some of
the remaining years um of the bond your
first year uh Bond payments are often
used for engineering surveys and
architecture fees and not sort of the
the people on the ground like like we're
like we can like we've been hearing all
day across the street digging with with
with heavy machinery that's nhs's
experience anyway um so those are those
are just the two or three primary
concerns that nsba has we believe that
this is sort of limiting voter Choice
from the voters being allowed to adopt
either a a flat number or a fixed
percentage to being tied into one
particular formula and we think that the
voters should have some flexibility with
how they how they want to do that within
their within their own local tax cap and
I'm happy to answer any
questions representative kahill thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question do you think it's fair to say
that the taxpayers that are maybe
struggling with a lot of bills right now
inflation high taxes um they're not
filling this room right now because
possibly they're at work and they
elected us to be their voice fair enough
representative absolutely thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony
again miss heck you're
[Music]
up good afternoon again chairman turat
members of the committee for the record
my name is Katherine heck and I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and well um I believe uh the
sponsors of the bill who introduced the
bill and did a great job um covering it
really summed up some of the work we did
together in the Senate on this local
option I did want to just make sure I
was here to answer any questions and to
just clarify a few points that I heard
um one of the first questions I heard um
well first let me also say that we are
really only concerned at nhma with the
section of the bill that goes up until
page two line 10 because the rest really
applies to a school district and that is
just not the area that we get into but
we had sat with the sponsors when we saw
this bill to make sure that Not only was
some language on a bill that we had
worked on on in this body around tax
caps was included um in the first
section of the bill that was seen in
this committee but making sure that
there was some definitions put in and
some understanding of different indices
and how they work so for example um we
wanted to ensure that well CPI is an
excellent indicator for perhaps a school
district because it's often used for
cost of living adjustments in colas it
may not be as accurate of a measure as
the municipal cost index which estimates
that they uh Municipal and County uh
American city and county magazine rather
has been doing this for 60 years and
they use a weight ated indices using CPI
construction index and Industrial
commodity index because we build roads
we build Bridges there's buildings um
and so and the Consumer Price Index so
they merge all of those together and
have different weights using data that
shows that our typical budgets have less
um salaries and benefits attached than
say a school district where we normally
see a higher percentage of the District
budget being attributed to salary and
benefits so that was a suggestion that
we appreciated that the sponsors um and
the committee um included in the bill um
another point that was brought up which
is a great question we also struggle
with when and where to get population
figures from so we did work with the
sponsors on this to ensure that they
were using RSA 78a which is the same
measure because we needed some
standardized method that every city in
town or every town rather this doesn't
apply to cities could use in the event
that they choose locally to adopt this
option via the voter and this is used
for our meals and rooms population
numbers or Highway block grant numbers
and other formula grants this is the
same statute that's already being used
and applied to other types of Grants
we're receiving so again we just wanted
the law to be very clear um should it be
adopted that it could be
enacted I don't think I have any more
comments other than to say that all of
our concerns in technical issues unless
we've missed any were addressed in in
the Senate through
amendments
questions representative
yell um did you say that you were
speaking in favor opposed or neutral we
are we are neutral on the bill it is a
um local option piece of
legislation oh and I would I I should
also add I heard about cities in tax
caps cities in their Charters have got
to place in a tax cap provision as part
of their Charter process which is
adopted by their legislative bodies and
several of our cities do use an
inflation index or an inflationary
measure as part of their tax cap so I
think this might have been some of the
reason we're considering this option
here it's being used in several of the
city
Charters representative kahill yes had a
question about that um so you're stating
that the cities in their Charter have a
tax cap are they allowed to be a City
without a tax cap I I
believe we can ask n but I my
understanding is that the charter has to
um have some type of provision with
contained within it for their budgeting
purposes because they have elected
officials they have representative
legislative bodies they do not have a
town meeting the way our communities do
because they would not have a way to
override they don't have a overriding
tax cap the way our local towns can
actually override the tax cap in this
legislation has does not preclude that
from happening either that stays the
same as current
law I see no other hands you're free to
go rep uh Miss heck thank
you okay uh last pink card I have is
Eric power
good afternoon committee members Eric
power from Brookline president of school
district governance Association speaking
in favor of this bill um I'm just gonna
I sent something out to the committee
this morning you may or have it in your
box but I want to just kind of highlight
a few of the the the points about the
positive aspects of this bill and answer
any questions that have come up um
section one talks about the local tax
cap it's the existing RSA 32b hyphen 325
hyphen B it's really a tax effort cap
for people that aren't aware so what
you're limiting is the tax effort from
year to year and currently the only
option is to do that by a fixed
percentage or a fixed dollar amount so
the a tax effort is really your total
budget minus your estimated Revenue VES
so that's that's what's available today
and I have experience with tax caps um
in Brookline in 2016 for our Brookline
School District we adopted an 8% tax cap
on our school district we had originally
proposed it at the 4% level but there
was concern about potential
inflation voters like the idea of a tax
cap but they didn't they felt that
inflation sometime might go high and
unfortunately that came true so but they
did so they did we did um adjust that at
the deliberative session under s SP2 and
it passed by the super majority vote of
60% needed more than 60% so this has got
to be a very much of an agreement for a
town to do this it's not just a simple
majority so what this bill does is it
gives you other other options doesn't
take that one away those are still
available if you want the fix percentage
or the fixed dollar amount this just
gives one that's makes a lot more sense
in terms of you know risk in terms of
you could have uh you can go with the
inflation factor that you choose for
your town MCI is a great one the EC
employment cost index is another popular
one
CPI you can choose that instead of a
fixed
percentage and um the other thing that
happens with the local tax cap is that a
if you get more revenues you can
increase your budget so it because it's
limiting tax effort but if if you get
more Revenue you can raise your spending
it's because the net would be the same
under the tax cap um the one thing
that's not the greatest piece of about
the tax cap is you adopt it with a super
majority but it can be overridden by a
simple majority at the town meeting or
School District meeting but that's the
way it is right now we're not trying to
change
that so the second part of the bill in
section two talks about School District
budget cap
and that's a spending cap so that
actually looks at how much you're
spending regardless of income again that
one has to be adopted by a 60% super
majority and that is done by selecting a
cost per
student whatever your whatever cost per
student you what the the legislative
body wants they pick a cost per student
and then they multiply by the number of
students which we use the uh Department
of Education average daily member ship
in Residence
admr and then also an inflation Factor
just like you could choose in the in the
local tax
cap again it puts a limit on the total
budget and spending so if you get more
revenues you don't get to increase the
budget that some people like that some
people don't like that but what that
would do is if you got higher revenues
it would actually go back to the
taxpayers as tax relief that's what's
built in there it limits the spending
you have the spending if you get more
revenues then it goes down and reduces
the tax effort which reduces taxes some
people like it some people don't um in
general you know higher revenues so
higher revenues don't raise the budget
cap higher
inflation will raise it because that's
that's a factor there and if you have
more students it goes up but if you have
less students that's a factor that makes
it go down so again with this with this
School District budget cap it was
authored to uh be overridden with a
three- fifth super majority so you have
to stay within the cap unless your
legislative body get your town meeting
or your deliberative session decides to
go above the cap with a super
majority and there is a there is a trend
in New Hampshire right now if you look
across the state that there's School
spending the motivation for this there
school spending is going up but the
populations are going down and the cost
per student is rising so there's clearly
uh a need for some taxpayers and some
school districts to want this um
I sent to you a graph I I served on a
stud what they call the bucom study
committee in Brooklyn I was the chairman
of it in 2020 and what we did is we
looked at we were looking at the impacts
of a budget committee but one of the
factors we did was we looked at what was
happening with school districts peer
school districts and peer towns and with
towns we were looking at how much has
the spending gone up compared to
inflation and the growth in population
and for school districts we looking at
what's happening with inflation and the
number of students and in for the school
districts we had 27 peer school
districts over 70% were exceeding the
what you would expect for uh a budget
going up based on inflation and uh
student enrollment which only 30% were
staying underneath that so there's CLE
clearly a need there I also have a graph
in there showing an example of um a
budget cap School District budget cap
and a local tax cap adopted with CPI
what it would look like and really it's
not drastic and it's not crazy but it
causes small changes to happen over time
so you're you don't get runaway budgets
as we're seeing
today the um there the in the in the the
uh package I emailed you this morning
there's also a couple of examples
showing how the School District budget
cap Works based on change ing
enrollments and inflation factors
whether you have a fixed number or
you're using an inflation Factor so you
can see how it works it's all in all
part of the um the packet I sent you and
I can answer questions if you have any
other detailed questions on that but I
think it makes a lot of sense to have a
a local tax cap that'll be much more
popular than what we have today today
there's I think there's seven towns and
three school districts that have adopted
a local tax cap primarily because you
can only pick the fixed percentage
or you can pick the fixed dollar amount
so this actually gives something that
vot more voters would come on board with
um because they would realize they'll be
protected from inflation if we get
inflation the tax Capital will go up
with it and that makes a lot more sense
so it would be a lot more popular um so
I would recommend um aop pass with
Amendment on this bill I think it's a
great tool it is enabling legislation it
has to be adopted by a 60% super
majority so no one's going to be forced
to use it but it is a tool that's
available to towns and school districts
thank you very much thank you questions
representative
stavis just wondering in all of your
calculations of school expenditures and
enrollment profil and the like how did
the education Freedom accounts factor
into that they're they're
independent is there an estimate of
what people are paying for
those that's not part of local school
district
spending so it's it doesn't impact tax
impact tax
caps further
questions I see none thank you very much
for your
testimony that was the last pink card I
had on S SP 383 I see nobody else
jumping up to come speak so with that we
will close the public hearing on SB 383
all right um that's it for today again
next Tuesday 9:30 we will hear two bills
in the morning and then start uh
executing some of these bills
here uh one of them we were informed
today that it's an early bill which
means uh SP 385 which we haven't heard
yet we will hear next Tuesday we have to
get it out on Tuesday so be prepared to
possibly along day or be prepared for
that one other than that enjoy your
Waters of the world